you
good morning everyone
i'm representative michael vose chair of
the house science technology and energy
committee and i would like to welcome
you all
to our
[Music]
january 25th session
we have a
agenda today that will allow us to hear
five bills
and at the conclusion of today's
hearings we will have heard 15 of the 25
bills that have been assigned to us
for
this
this year in the biennium
i have decided that we need to complete
our early bills
by february 7th so i'm scheduling an
executive session on monday february 7th
at one o'clock in this room
we will deal with the five early bills
that have been assigned to us
i didn't write the the numbers down so i
can't give them to you off the top of my
head but
uh
you'll you'll see them we've heard them
all so far so you'll you'll see them
when you
when you look at the calendar notice
that will be posted
either later today or tomorrow
representative calipis did you have a
will we still be meeting on february 8th
yes we will meet on february 8th to hear
okay and when i follow up are we going
to have any time to discuss besides the
executive session
those first five bills
well i was about to announce oh okay
that we are going to form one
subcommittee
possibly make some changes to house bill
there has been some
interest
will at least
bring attention to the problem if
nothing else
i'm forming a subcommittee
that will be comprised of
representative doug thomas who will
chair the subcommittee
representative jeanine notter
representative nick white
representative
lucas partial
and
i need one other volunteer to round out
the committee
preferably from
the democratic side so
representative callie pitts you are the
fifth member of the subcommittee
the subcommittee will meet
although the meeting hasn't been
officially scheduled yet the
subcommittee will meet on monday january
yes
we just formed a subcommittee
for hb 1644.
you've been assigned to that
subcommittee
and the subcommittee will meet on monday
january 31st
at a time to be determined by chairman
thomas
and
the subcommittee will make a
recommendation
for potential changes
to hb 6
1644 and i'm going to turn the
microphone over to representative thomas
to give you a brief synopsis of some of
the ideas that the subcommittee will
explore representative thomas
thank you mr chair uh just keeping it
brief
uh i would like to be able to go over
just a little background of the
technology involved in 5g so we get a
slight understanding of what we're
talking about here i know some of you
have been doing research so have we so
we'll cover that a little bit
and also is my desire that we want to
come up with a
a bill that
both acknowledges the public's plight at
the same time acknowledging the
types of evidence that is out there or
lack thereof and to come up with an
amenable
bill that would
be able to bring attention to
the issue in terms of maybe
less than what the bill is saying but
but also saying that we want to be
careful
on on what and where we do these things
so
at the at this working group
i'd like to come up with some
issues and words that we can put there
that can kind of
call attention at the same time
recognize the fact that some people do
have issues and we just need to to
okay thank you representative thomas so
does anybody have a question
representative partial has a question
yes thank you chair
um we were discussing continuing the
hearings on this particular bill at a
later date at the last session and
it will not be possible to hear
any additional testimony prior to the
subcommittee
um
i think we do what we need to do
but are you planning on additional
hearings
at this point you know i had forgotten
that we had recessed that hearing and we
really should complete the hearing
before we have an executive session
shouldn't we
so it's entirely possible that uh i will
schedule the last hour of the public
hearing at one o'clock on monday the 7th
and then we'll start the executive
session at 2 o'clock
i think that's the
the only solution that we can offer
so the the subcommittee will have to do
its work prior to that
even though we won't hear the we've
heard enough testimony i believe on that
bill two and a half hours that i think
the subcommittee can do its its work i
have confidence in that and thank you
for your answer okay thank you all right
any additional questions uh
representative nader
did you say the names of the uh
representatives who will be on the
subcommittee i did but to review they
are representative thomas will chair the
subcommittee representatives notter and
white will be on the subcommittee as
will representatives partial and jackie
kelly pitts
thank you mr chairman you're welcome
anything else before we get into the
seeing none
i would like now to
open the public hearing on house bill
fn
okay
i forgot the pledge so we're going to do
the pledge first then we're going to
open the public hearing on hb 1459
everybody please rise
and join representative john lewicki who
my apologies for overlooking the pledge
i usually like to do that as the very
first item of business
okay so now we can move on with the
public hearing to house bill 1459 fn
relative to recycling solar panels
and i would like to
turn the floor over to the
sponsor of the bill
the
committee clerk
testimony representative fred platt it's
all yours thank you mr chair
thank you for your indulgence listening
to my testimony
this bill established as a program and
fund for the recycling of photovoltaic
solar panels it's modeled after a law
adopted in the state of washington
chapter 70.355 rcw
california has a rule to facilitate
recycling that took effect in january
21.
some states such as new jersey and north
carolina passed laws in 2020
to require the study of end-of-life pv
management options to help develop
options for legislative or regulatory
considerations
as of may 2020 hawaii had pending
legislation that would require
comprehensive study of issues related to
pv
model module recycling and end of life
management
rhode island has considered legislation
that if enacted would create a pv module
manufacturer stewardship and take back
program so this is certainly not
restricted to new hampshire this idea
in most cases most states the
responsibility of residential solar
panel disposal currently falls on
homeowners adding another financial
barrier to solar technology depending on
the type of solar panel
solar waste has the potential to leach
hazardous materials such as cadmium lead
silver telluride and selenium into soil
and water which could harm surrounding
communities and ecosystems close to 100
of the materials in a solar panel are
recyclable or reusable but the heavy
metals are a concern
the panels also have adhesives and
sealants to make breaking them apart
challenging solar panels are complicated
to recycle
most solar panel recyclers can
mechanically recover the layers of glass
aluminum and copper wiring however
strategy for strategies for improving
recovery of the semiconductor layer
especially the market dominant silicon
are being developed by a limited number
of companies in the united states
the legit the longevity of these panels
the way they're put together and how
they make them make it inherently
difficult to use a term d manufacturers
said mark robards director of special
projects for ecs refining one of the
largest electronics recycles and
recyclers in the u.s the panels are torn
apart mechanically and broken down with
acids to separate out the crystalline
silicon the semiconductor material used
by most photovoltaic managers
manufacturers heat systems are used to
burn up the adhesives that bind them to
their armatures and acidic hydro
metallic metallurgical systems are used
to separate precious metals
the manufacturer could choose to
contract with solar recycling companies
to to effect the take back a quick
internet search will identify several
companies
through 2020 153 megawatts of solar
panels have been installed in new
hampshire
389 megawatts are projected through
2025.
the installations are rapidly
proliferating and that means there will
be a lot of solar panels heading for the
scrap pile
panels may have an economic life of 15
or to 30 years or less
some installed early in the period of
solar growth may be headed to the scrap
heap already
decommissioned pv modules could total 1
million tons of waste in the united
states by 2030 or 1 of the world's
e-waste
what is the solar panels used for life
just like a lot of other other equipment
solar panels don't perform at 100 for
their entire life and then just stop
working in your 30.
instead solar panels are very slow rate
produce less electricity as they age
this process is called degradation
because of solar panel degradation most
panels production warranties changes
they age manufacturers typically
guarantee 90 percent of the panel's
production until
for the first 10 years
after 10 years that percentage drops
back to 80 for the remaining 15 to 20
years after the system's used for life
the panel can go
panels can go on producing electricity
but at a diminished rate so economics
may dictate replacement with new panels
especially if new solar panels become
more efficient and cheaper
this is an incipient problem and getting
ahead of it as this bill does saves
precious landfill space and major costs
to municipal or private waste management
entities
money by keeping the panels out of the
waste stream
i quote a useful paper from a national
renewal
energy lab in eppery electric power
research institute that i used to work
for
um it's https www.nrel.gov
forward slash docs flow
slash fy21 osti forward slash 74124.pdf
and it's in the testimony so you can
key it in the difference between solar
panels and other power production is
that solar panels are dispersed through
a large area each being a relatively
little economic value at end of life
central station power plants can be an
army remanufactured or repurposed on the
other hand in conclusion this bill
anticipates a problem will certainly
come about without addressing it several
states have already done so i'm open for
questions thank you
thank you representative plett before i
open the floor to questions on this bill
i would like to remind everyone in the
audience
that if you wish to speak on this bill
you need to fill out a pink card
i should have and submit it to uh
us up here
and fred you can submit yours later you
don't have to do it right this minute
okay thank you okay so with that we'll
open the floor to questions and uh i see
representative callie fitz has a
question
uh thank you for taking my question the
uh
this
this wants to set up a fund
yes now
if i'm
thinking straight
who would get the benefit of this fund
the manufacturer the persons who install
the i'm thinking that these are for
homeowners
it's for anybody uh who has a solar
system that needs to come down so that
the cost of removal is removed from the
burden from the homeowner or
business and is put on the manufacturer
follow up my follow-up would be if this
fund it becomes
available and the manufacturer is no
longer available
then what happens they have to feed they
have to put money into the fund so it
doesn't make any difference whether
they're available or not
so so this is the
solar panels are installed they fund
okay thank you representative mcgee has
a question
thank you mr chairman before you begin
representative mcgee let me just remind
everyone of microphone etiquette
please turn on your microphone
before you speak and turn it off after
you speak okay thank you everybody thank
you
thank you for taking my question
representative plutt um i applaud you
for bringing this i think it's it's
definitely true that we need to be
paying more attention to our our solid
waste streams and how we're dealing with
technical uh you know uh
mechanical waste obviously and uh and
anything that can be leaching into the
system as you mentioned in your
testimony
my question is whether you have talked
with
the waste management group at des about
this because i actually
co-sponsored a bill also about waste a
bottle bill this this term
and i think we have sort of a larger
problem with how we're managing all of
it and i was wondering if they might be
brought in because they do have a waste
management
group or you know some individuals that
are dedicated to how new hampshire is
doing waste management
and in fact i did they've reviewed the
bill they're not taking a position on it
but they thought it was uh the person i
thought it was well written but not
taking a position i agree
thanks um so the other thing i would ask
about
is the
the position of
providing
the extra cost on the manufacturer up
front
and whether you have found any
indication that that would be a
disincentive for people to
to
supply
solar panels in the state of new
hampshire like do you think it would
inhibit inhibit them from doing business
here
if so
oh well
we need to take care of the problem at
hand which is to which is to take care
of the waste stream if that's a
disincentive that's not the intention
but it's it's a part of the total cost
of the
product
okay thank you representative mcgee
um
i have a question representative plett
is the
overriding
purpose of this legislation
to protect
our cities and towns
from future costs of handling this waste
themselves which would be a burden to
taxpayers absolutely either the cities
and towns and filling up landfills but
also homeowners and businesses that may
be stuck with some of that cost
okay thank you representative mcwilliams
has a question
thank you chairvoz and thank you
representative plett for the
presentation i think that this is
incredibly timely because we've been
talking about land filling materials and
landfills filling up in new hampshire
this last legislative session and so
this is really helpful to see a stance
on solar panels so thank you for your
research and drafting this
i currently have a bill regarding
construction waste and debris um and
mandating that it be diverted from our
waste stream so it doesn't end up in
landfills um
and so i'm curious if you could see this
working for construction debris as well
as solar panels
i certainly have no pride of authorship
in fact the
the words came from washington state
modified by our ols so if you see some
way to tweak the wording for
construction debris go have at it i i
will say in my town anyway we do divert
construction debris and it goes to a
separate processing facility so it
doesn't go into landfill some of it
eventually does but a lot of it is
recycled yeah okay um that's great and
then the second piece follow up
thank you chair
the second piece is same question for
the automotive industry could you see
this applying to cars and sale of cars
in new hampshire
uh possibly i i think that the cars
already have a robust recycling process
because there's value in the metals and
because there's such value in the metals
a program like this may not be necessary
because there's enough residual values
to to make the recycling worth
the candle so
but that wouldn't be true thank you
representative mcwilliams
thomas is recognized
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
how do you see this bill interacting or
how would it act with um
say homeowners
for instance that are leasing solars
versus ones that that own them
if a homeowner leases the system the
homeowner should have no obligation on a
financial obligation to remove it but
the least less sore will have that
obligation and if the lessor happens to
be the manufacturer problem solved
but
if it's a third party
this bill would provide some financial
relief to that lessor
follow-up
thank you mr thank you for the follow-up
question uh on a different note
would this bill apply to
any solar panels that are put on any of
our federal buildings in the state
airport and so forth
i hadn't thought through that but i
don't see why not a solar panel is a
solar panel
okay thank you
you aren't representative thomas i went
through my two questions i know i and i
thanked you for those two
okay representative samsung is
recognized
um thank you thank you
represent platt for bringing this bill
and i too applaud you for this idea
because
it is important for us to hold
manufacturers accountable for what they
make and how it's disposed of
why does this not apply to all
electronic waste
smartphones computers laptops it's the
same technology and often the materials
involved are significantly more than in
solar panels
so they need to be disposed of as
e-waste in many municipalities like ours
in portsmouth
and it seems to me this would be
why why can't we just put solar panels
in the same boat with e-waste a good
question uh thank you for the question i
think the difference is scale
in my town there is e-waste recycling
and i have to pay for it i may pay
fifteen dollars for a tv or ten dollar
fifteen dollars for
uh small electronics uh and so it is
taken care of
and
this program may be a little too
cumbersome
for small electronics like that but it
is being taken care of town by town
so it's not been going to the waste
not going into the waste
but um
i mean i'm aware of disassembling plants
in in europe now that are doing this
regularly with solar panels
um and uh it's it's becoming a big
industry there because manufacturers are
responsible for doing exactly what
you're proposing here
however
uh you're you're proposing here a state
program
uh why not let municipalities uh do the
same thing that they do now collect a
fee from
the
user of a solar panel when it gets
brought to your landfill
uh why why would we need a separate
state program for this
well i think it's the potential cost
involved in recycling
and the cost it would be imposed on on
the
person or business who has that solar
it's it's not a 20 tv it's something
much bigger than that that's why this i
think this program is necessary
thank you
thank you representative samsic
representative mann is recognized for a
question turn sideways a little bit
thank you mr chairman um this is just a
crazy thought um
wouldn't it be interesting to have uh i
i need to upgrade my solar panels i mean
might have been on my roof for quite a
while and they don't produce
what i really want i could really
increase it could we put the burden on
whoever is selling new panels
that was going to replace my panels on
my roof
put the burden on them to recycle the
ones that they remove
uh that's and um sorry if you weren't
done there's a way you know that would
be
instead of giving me discounts on the
price of the solar they would compete on
uh
being able to recycle cheaply
and uh
you know the business would be motivated
actually to
to uh to recycle in order to sell
upgrades
i'm
i don't quite speak english but uh is
that is that an interesting idea and
do you think that would work
you speak english very well i did
understand the question thank you
uh representative man
um that's something for you to negotiate
uh with a new installer to see if you
can pull it off but unfortunately the
person putting in the new solar panel
isn't responsible necessarily for the
manufacturer cost of the old solar panel
but that's something you could certainly
negotiate right
you need a follow-up representative matt
thank you thank you
okay uh representative white is
recognized for a question
have you looked into
excuse me how this would affect the cost
of a solar system
i really don't know
but the state washington state doesn't
seem to have slowed down solar
installations
thank you
uh representative partial is recognized
for a question
thank you chair votes and thank you uh
representative platt for your wonderful
testimony
um it seems to me what we're speaking of
here
um well first let me say i wish we had
this kind of foresight before adoption
of some other technology such as our
nuclear industry of how we dispose of
the ensuing waste
and it seems to be what we're talking
about is an extended producer
responsibility bill such as washington
state just enacted
um it plays the end of product liability
back onto the manufacturer and not to
taxpayers or consumers so i'm all for
this bill in theory
are you aware of h house bill one one
one one which addresses these same
issues broadly for all solid waste right
here in new hampshire
i am not and frankly i don't go around
remembering house bill numbers in my
head uh so so
i do i do if if i'm familiar with the
bill i remember it by its content not by
its number but no i'm not okay i
understand that and i would have the
same problem
i will say with respect i will say with
respect to nuclear power there is a
whole program federally imposed for
decommissioning of the plants and
there's a federal program the federal
government hasn't lived up for handling
the
the waste so so i do think that has been
taken care of
um
representative partial is behind
follow-up please in case you're trying
don't worry about it um i would love to
talk about the what you brought up this
now i first mentioned nuclear so pardon
me maybe that cloudy issue let me take
that back then
um but would you support a broader
approach that addresses electronics and
batteries and all these other products
that we're dealing with right now for
disposal and create more extender
more producer liability on these end
life products that's a good question and
the answer is maybe
and the reason the word maybe is because
this program may be too big a hammer for
the problem at hand on the other hand i
do see this extending to uh central
station batteries uh
and uh
the the uh and automotive batteries i
could see it extending to when we have a
viable
electric car industry that's going to be
a huge amount of batteries that need
recycling
thank you so much for
answers
okay
additional questions representative
notter is recognized
thank you mr chairman may i ask a
question of representative mann
at this time uh that's not typically the
way we do things if that gets me off the
stand
if that gets me off the stand i'm all
for it
maybe you could do that offline
i'm wondering if the questions that have
come up and there's a lot of questions
previous
dealings with recycling and how
some of the countries are not doing that
anymore and how it's very difficult to
do it and
would you
be amenable to making this a study to
look into the cost issues to how they'd
be handled who would handle them
and
instead of just going forward and saying
we're going to do this
without all or a lot of the details in
place
if that is the
will of the committee i could i
certainly wouldn't fight that but i
think it has been put in place in
washington state
and it has worked so i'm not sure a
follow-up one follow-up
do we have the details or any of the
details from washington state and is
this the exact verbiage
it's pretty much the exact verbiage of
washington state uh it's
of course modified to new hampshire so
they had a depart a division we don't
have so in our cases environmental
services
so
the the agency names have changed but
it's essentially
exact verbiage
thank you
thank you representative pimentel is
recognized for a question thank you mr
chairman uh thank you representative
plett
and uh thank you for taking this on i
appreciate
any recycling that we can do
as a country
there's a lot of
products that
basically when they get replaced
there is a fee attached to them things
like tires
which pays for the proper disposal
of the one that was just removed
um
that's inst i don't know if it's a
federal law or
a state law but wouldn't that be a
simpler way of dealing with panels so
that when they're actually removed
uh there would be a fee attached for
uh interesting question thank you
representative pimentel and and the
concern i have is the size of the fee to
cover the cost it's one thing when
you're dealing with a small radio or tv
or a tire
but it's another thing when you're
dealing with the massive amount of
panels that need recycling so that fee
might be exorbitant so the whole purpose
of the bill is to shift that cost to the
manufacturer
do you need a follow-up
uh thank you
mr chairman but
whether we pay before or after
wouldn't we still be paying
it's
if there's a cost imposed on the
manufacturer up front because of this
bill
i certainly would think that the
manufacturer would try to build that
into the upfront cost of the panel
maybe but competition might keep that
from happening so i can't answer the
question uh
but it's it's true that some of those
costs the the homeowner may be paying
one way or another but but i can't say
that all of those costs are passed on to
the homeowner or business some of them
may be absorbed through competitive
pressures
thank you thank you representative um
the wiki is recognized for a question
give us the chairman uh thank you
representative um i see us going all
over the map here talking about
automotive waste and so forth and
perhaps it would be better to stick with
the subject i know that well perhaps as
a question are you aware of the program
where the autopsy stores will take a
battery no questions asked and give you
a ten dollar credit
i i
have done that myself but i'm not sure
what that gets what's that got to do
don't forget to turn your mic back on
when you speak okay um no but thank you
it's just that we seem to be all over
the map we're talking about electronic
waste automotive waste and so forth and
we've got one specific thing and i think
it might be better to concentrate
thank you
uh
representative mcgee is recognized for a
question thank you mr chairman
um i'm just looking at the fiscal note
and it the last sentence says it should
be noted the bill uh provides neither an
appropriation nor authority for the
establishment of the new position that
it
it discusses
us needing in order to sort of
administer having a program like this so
i was just wondering if you had any
thoughts about whether
we we might need to define an
appropriation for the state to be able
to
implement the program
my answer is that this will go to the uh
finance committee from it is if it's a
fn
um and the reason why it's not uh
funding if funding isn't identified
above is because it says it's in uh
fiscal year 24 and 25 and so they'll
have to maybe give that
at least note that so when it before
implementation it is approved by the
okay thank you
okay
any uh additional questions
i have an additional question
and that is
since it's likely that when a solar
system comes to the end of its life it's
not just one panel
would the cost of disposing of those
solar panels be quite high
and
should there be some kind of a an
arrangement such as the one you propose
to make that cost
less difficult for the person who's
recycling his panels to accomplish
uh yes thank you for the question i
think that's the whole purpose of the
bill
is to is to remove is to shift cost
burden from the homeowner or business to
to the manufacturer
and provide a program for safe recycling
i will say that in many cases
solar panels can go a long time before
they in fact do need to be scrapped or
recycled
even though with lesser output they may
find
a use with that lesser output but
eventually they'll have to be scrapped
and that's what this program is about
okay my follow-up question then is
let's say i buy solar panels for my
house
but then i sell my house
and the sec the owner who owns the house
after me
after
say 20 years decides he needs to replace
those solar panels
would he get hit with uh additional fees
when he goes to do that recycling the in
my view of this bill with the bill
that the homeowner he or she
can go to the
des and get get the cost of removal
covered without the bill yes they'll be
stuck with costs
all right seeing no further questions
for representative plett oh
did i miss you representative partial go
ahead yes thank you chair that's one
more quick question
um
i i do like this bill very much and i
really think it's a time that we stop
passing hidden costs along to the
consumers
my only concern is that this product
that this bill
maybe should be addressing some of these
other issues that have been said are
tangential i mean it's i feel it does
single out the solar panel industry
when there's
other industries that would benefit from
the same approach of uh extended
producer responsibility
and i'd like to hear your comment on
that if i may okay i'm going to use a
word i invented i'm dealing with a son
who's been seven through seven years of
bad health
uh and
he's been struggling to get along to a a
a a healthy uh state and he's close
but he's having to do the same thing
over and over and over every day so he
invented the word of the
one foot in front of the other
and so let's get this one passed and i
may very well come back next year with
something to extend it to uh central
station and automotive batteries in in
electric cars
and about one foot in front of the other
and see where the need is
okay follow up then yeah follow up do
you think we could get more of an uh
economy of scale if we did take the
entire problems on square you know uh
uh
what's you know that's rather than
you know that's
sail right towards the enemy as it were
um do you think we get more accomplished
by
um
addressing multiple issues with the same
kind of uh approach you're taking here
which i think is a good approach
and my answer is possibly
but i'm not expert enough uh and so it'd
have to involve des and others in in
that discussion and my afraid of putting
too many uh bulbs on the christmas tree
is that the christmas tree might fall
over that we will let's get something
passed and then grow from there sure
thank you so much for those answers
good analogy about the christmas tree
you may have noticed uh members of the
committee that i have uh my excuse
not yet not yet
i have allowed more than the two
question per member limit
so far in this discussion
and i have done that on purpose because
i have scheduled this hearing for two
hours in anticipation that there would
be a lot of discussion i think a robust
discussion of this issue
is worthwhile
and as a result i've decided to waive
our requirement that each member be
limited to two questions
because i only have one other pink card
that's been submitted
for testimony on this bill so we have
plenty of time
so if any of you were wondering about
that that's the reason i have done that
so i will allow some additional
questions since we do have time
representative samsic indicated that he
has a question
yeah thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative
um so
i want to underscore the idea that we
need we should take a more comprehensive
view of all this waste because
as you mentioned solar panels have a
lifetime of a life
a long life of 20 years more more
but cell phones
laptops computers
three four years
and they're piling up like crazy in our
landfill and not landfills but in our
recycling centers
and
the materials in there are both more
valuable and more toxic than anything in
a solar panel
so
in the one one hand it's good to deal
with this but this is a problem that
right now in new hampshire especially
where we have so little solar energy
installed
we probably have 20 years before we have
any significant amount of panels to to
let landfill or dispose of
versus every three years everyone's
getting a new cell phone everyone's
getting a new laptop
those are all the same type of
technologies
and with many more valuable materials
and many more toxic materials included
compared to a solar panel
so it seems to me if we're going to make
some rules and and set up a fund
for disposal of these materials for
solar
it would make a lot of sense to include
the
the other technologies and waste that's
very typical of this this type of
technology
in this bill as well because
already causing a problem whereas the
solar panel waste is going to be
several years before we see significance
don't you think we should include that
as well considering the lifetime of
i think i addressed that with earlier
questions
and it's it's a matter of scale
and some of the cell phones
and so on do have a
recycling process so you find boxes to
put them in in towns they have places to
put them and they are being recycled and
and
this sort of bill may be a little too
cumbersome for something that small
but but which are being addressed anyway
but i i'm open uh if there's some future
date let's see if we can't get something
passed and build on it
thank you
representative thomas is recognized for
a question
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
recognizing that solar panels
are in a different category in my
opinion on some of the other
equipment that was mentioned because
they are big time producers of
electricity
as opposed to a cell phone so i think
they might fall into a special case but
i was wondering
have you received any feedback at all
from
anybody here in the state
in the solar panel industry on your bill
or any suggestions thereof
i would have thought that this bill
would have attracted huge attention so
i'm just kind of curious if anyone has
spoken to you about it at all i'd be
curious to know what their thoughts are
on that the only people who've spoken to
me at all on this bill
are from des
uh when
michael wimsat and i forget the
young man working for him have reviewed
this bill i've not gotten any uh
feedback from anybody in the solar
industry or anywhere else except uh
articles newspaper uh
articles that were posted which were not
complementary from some of the solar
industry but have not seen anything
directly
follow-up
i'll do a follow-up thank you mr chair
thank you for the follow-up so uh
michael north i'm sorry
the the the article you mentioned the
articles you mentioned in in the paper
we're not directed solely at you
so
i can can would you assume
say for that article that there's not a
whole lot of
concern on this bill from the solar
industry since no one has talked to you
or is here to testify i've learned not
to
attribute motives or to anybody else
that i can only say i introduced this
bill i've had no feedback and you can
read however you wish it to read
representative callie pitts is
recognized
sorry fred my mind is working a little
slow today
uh i'm thinking
that not the majority of solar panels
are not manufactured in the united
states
we see a lot of distribution i see
installers
but i don't
know
what the percentages of
manufactured panels in the us
am i correct in my assumption that most
of the panels come from overseas and my
how do we
you know what's the litigation process
or what's the process of forcing
a country or an another
a manufacturer in a different country
to contribute to a fund so those were
two questions ahead well my
understanding is they have to contribute
up front so they want to sell their
panel they'll have to contribute uh and
and like my concern
uh
is if the moral manufacturing were in
the united states you're right a lot of
it's from china i think the uh the view
of solar panels may be somewhat
different because there's a lot of
mining of stuff
and we won't tolerate it but china it's
okay
okay additional questions representative
pimentel
thank you mr chairman uh thank you
representative uh
a lot of other
areas of the world like the eu
and a lot of other countries
have within their borders
um
essentially stuff what we're talking
about with this bill where there is a
mandatory recycling of these panels
and as you heard from uh
uh representative sanchez
they have
break down these
panels
and actually recycle 95 of what
i guess my question is
that's it doesn't seem to fit an economy
of scale
and i also
wonder if that is going to
affect
solarized so to speak
compared to the rest of new england and
the rest of the country
i'm not sure that was i'm sure i
understand the question what i heard out
of it is
of something that i think i've answered
previously what the impact might be on
the solar industry and uh the amount of
installation and my answer was it's this
is a legitimate cost and if it slows it
down that's a side effect that's not the
intent but we have to take care of the
problem of a waste stream so keep it out
of the
transfer station out of the landfills
and keep heavy metals from polluting our
ground
our
uh our uh atmosphere so if that if this
has a chilling effect that's not the
purpose but my answer is so what it's
you need a follow-up representative
no thanks thank you miss uh rep
uh
representative samsic
thank you mr chairman and thank you
i i kind of wanted to um
underscore what
the previous representative just
mentioned
and i'm just wondering
um first of all
if this program were to be set up
where actually would the disassemble
wing of the panels happen
who would do this who would take these
panels to recover them to recycle them
and i say this because
as i mentioned before since 2018 the
very first disassembling plant in europe
in france has been set up
and it's
very impressive
uh highly robotic they can disassemble
and recover materials from one solar
panel within five minutes and it creates
huge economic stimulus for jobs for
technology and all that stuff which
would be great if we if new hampshire
became
a disassembler of solar panels as an
industry
however as was just mentioned we have so
little right now in this state and we're
such a small scale state
uh that i don't see us getting involved
in this issue uh proactively
representative samsich so you'll recall
that uh yeah two weeks ago we talked
about not making speeches sorry about
that okay mr chairman you have a
question to extract some information i
think there was a question
are you suggesting that we create
disassembling facilities in new
hampshire no
if that happened i'd be all for it but
but
there's a role for government the role
for government is bills like this the
role for government isn't to create
manufacturing let it happen and if you
look if you look
on the web and as i said on my testimony
there were several it's a nascent
industry the recycling industry but
there were several set up across the
country to do just this
and
so if that happens in new hampshire fine
if it doesn't find as long as it's taken
care of and
who i don't know but there's several out
there to go to
okay thank you representative flett i
detect that the questions are starting
to get repetitive
so i'm going to thank you for your
testimony on this bill
and we're going to move on to our next
presenter
so i'd like to call on sam evans brown
representing clean energy new hampshire
thank you mr chair and thank you to the
committee my name is sam evans brown i'm
the executive director of clean energy
new hampshire
we are a small non-profit policy
advocacy organization
that represents individuals and
businesses across the state of new
hampshire that are interested
in
the state having good policies to
encourage a transition to clean energy
uh indeed many of our business members
do include representatives of the the
solar installer uh workforce that would
be impacted by this bill
and and we have some concerns
we would be very open to working with
representative plett to uh to address
those concerns because the solar
industry writ large i think is very
interested in answering this question of
what to do
at the end of the life of these solar
panels i think the feeling is just that
perhaps as as representative platt
himself said that this is a rather large
hammer
when when the problem has yet to yet to
materialize
um i think if you that just sort of to
pull back a bit if you look around
yourself right now we're surrounded by
all sorts of goods uh you know tables
carpets
light bulbs cars
all of which are allowed to be built and
sold to consumers without any sort of
stewardship plan
that that determines what will happen to
them at the end of their life
and and solar panels while they are
quite large do have a long life uh in
fact the the the length of service of
the solar panel is somewhat
indeterminate there was a great article
in the concord monitor a number of years
ago where the author tried to track down
the oldest solar panel in the state and
found one that was 40 years old and
still producing power
so uh
you know the lifespan that was cited in
in the in the representatives testimony
was perhaps a bit on the short side and
and uh i would highlight the fact that
there is in fact an a an nrel study from
the national renewable energy laboratory
that talks about the thriving salvage
market for panels that are pulled off
the pulled out of installations um so it
is not clear that after the the you know
warranty
service life of 25 years that solar
panels will immediately go into into the
landfill um and as several
representatives have pointed out there
will be a large volume of solar panels
that are coming out of service you know
several decades from now and and i think
there's the opportunity to let the
private market step up and uh provide
the service of recycling those panels
that that we allow the private market to
do for all of the other consumer goods
that surround you here today
um
i think you know representative ple
cited that by 2030 we might have a
million tons of solar panels going into
solar panels very briefly i googled what
percentage of the american waste stream
that would represent that would be less
than one percent of the american waste
stream assuming and that's assuming that
every solar panel that was taken out of
service was immediately landfilled as
opposed to uh sold into the salvage
market or recycled for for parts um as
as is done today in fact uh we we uh in
our testimony cite the the
decommissioning plan of the fitzwilliam
solar site the chinook uh solar array
that was the 30 megawatt array that was
built
was
approved by the site evaluation
committee a few years ago and they have
a very robust decommissioning plan
that's built into that
approval that includes the the installer
covering the full cost of uh returning
the site to pre-construction condition
and indicates that not only will all the
solar panels be recycled but even the
the foundations and the chain-link
fences will be recycled from that
project so again i would i would just
highlight that perhaps this is a uh
a
solution that the private market can
provide on its own already
that said you know when it comes to
smaller smaller installations
residential installations and municipal
installations there is perhaps a role
for the state to do something like it
does with the recycling of tires um and
and perhaps that is something that we we
should be thinking about proactively um
i would simply
uh ask the question of why
why it would be that solar panels which
you know in the worst case scenario
would represent a tiny fraction of our
total solid waste stream should be in
this special category uh and with that
i'll take any questions that the
committee may have
thank you mr evans brown for your
testimony looking for questions now for
uh mr evans brown and i recognize
representative thomas for a question
uh thank you mr chair thank you for
taking my question i
uh first let me preface my comment my
question by saying i i
am continue continuously frustrated when
government is aware of a problem but
kicks the can down the road because they
don't want to deal with it right now
it always costs us more later on to fix
it
but in terms of
the solar panels
why
they they produce a large amount of
electricity they're producers
and
it i can't
believe that in time would do you
believe that you know what this is not a
do you believe question but but with
technology changing all the time
if there's not a way to recycle
existing solar panels and new technology
comes out that the solar industry wants
to
sell a new improved version of a panel
but the
but they can't because people
they they don't want to get rid of the
old ones but uh if there was a recycling
program developed now where they could
get rid of their old panels and and buy
new improved ones would wouldn't that be
helpful for both the the environment
recycling and the solar industry if we
did if we did develop a program now
as a way to to get rid of solar panels
uh i'm i'm not suggesting that the
recycling of solar panels is not a good
thing and not a desirable outcome that
the state should be working towards the
question is merely why why would the
state feel the need to step in right now
and create such a program as opposed to
letting the private market step forward
and do so itself because there are a lot
of indications as representative samsic
laid out in the european example in
which the private market is going to do
exactly that um and and so you know
when we when we think about an
individual homeowner and their their
financial decision of of whether to
replace some old degraded
less efficient panels with newer shinier
more efficient ones that's simply an
economic decision that that individual
homeowner will make
and it's going to be based on a number
of factors including the salvage value
of the panels but also the installation
cost of of taking the old ones down and
putting the new ones up and so i i i
merely ask you know this is
your you prefaced your question by
saying that you're concerned when the
government sees problems and does
nothing about them if what we're
concerned about here is solid waste
i would encourage you to look up the
percentage of the various waste streams
that go into our landfills and attack
that problem and what you'll find is
that the vast majority of our solid
waste the largest tranche is organics
right so so we should perhaps develop a
composting program what we're concerned
about is solid waste
but what i'm i'm merely suggesting that
this may not actually be a problem the
private market may solve this problem
for the state
follow up
no follow-up thank you
okay no follow-up
i got a question about
if
looking at the alternative which is end
of use
uh
payment for disposal
and my question is would wouldn't that
encourage
the the owner of the panels
to either one
keep them longer despite
uh that their reduced uh
efficiency
and two
find an appropriate
place
to um
sell the panels
i will confess that i have not given a
great deal of thought as to what the
impacts of an end of end of life sort of
recycling fee a la what we do with tires
what type of effect that would have um i
think this the suppositions you lay out
seem seem reasonable and i think that
perhaps if if the committee does want to
look into
alternative language this bill that
might be something that we could that we
could work on together collaboratively
with the sponsor and with the department
of environmental services um
so so i think uh perhaps would be my
answer
thank you and wouldn't you
i guess i'm looking at infrastructure as
far as
the infrastructure for setting up the
pro
for
a program
laid out in the bill
as opposed to having
um
some sort of fee
at end of use and what what the
difference in the infrastructure costs
to the states
would be
uh that that i think is an excellent
point in particular when we when i look
at this bill uh there is a new position
created at the department of
environmental services there's not as
far as i can tell funding for that
position except for what could perhaps
be extracted from the manufacturers of
solar panels
representative cali pitts asked earlier
about how how many of those
manufacturers are in fact in the united
states the answer is less than one
percent of solar panels are manufactured
in the united states so so there's an
enforceability question as to whether
the state will be able to get
manufacturers to pay into a fund to
support a position
um so so i i think that if what we're
looking for is a solution to the end of
life to solar panels
something that is perhaps a lighter
touch
and and doesn't create so much
infrastructure as you put it could be it
thank you thank you
we have a few more questions i have one
myself
you mentioned in your written testimony
that the chinook solar
system solar project down in fitzwilliam
had a decommissioning plan as part of
its original
original project plan
now that's a solar a utility scale solar
project
and required the site evaluation
committee to
approve the project and the site
evaluation committee of course has rules
that require decommissioning
plans so my question is what about these
small residential solar systems you know
5 10 15 solar panels
what would you envision as being
an appropriate methodology to avoid
municipalities having to deal with
increased costs when a residence tries
to dispose of
solar panels
i would i would reiterate what i said in
my in the beginning of my testimony
which is that this is this is a concern
and trying to reduce our solid waste
stream is something that i think that is
in fact an appropriate role for the
government um but the question is why
why in particular are we concerned about
solar panels versus all of the other uh
large
and recyclable consumer goods that are
that are sold each year why are there no
stewardship plans for cars as was laid
out and the answer is because the
private market is allowed to step up and
and
provide solutions to
to goods that are still valuable um and
i i
am not averse and i think our members
are not averse to asking the question of
is there some sort of state program that
could encourage the recycling of these
materials i think that our membership
simply feels that the program that is
laid out in the bill as written is
perhaps a little heavy-handed
now what would i personally envision um
i would envision that a robust recycling
industry would would spring up
as the need as the need uh dictates and
that
i would suggest that a robust recycling
industry does not exist right now
because there's no need for one and
there's not a large volume of solar
panels that are being decommissioned as
of yet
okay thank you following up on that
question
there are municipal municipal plans in
place currently to charge people to
recycle
certain types of of materials for
example
in order for me to take a refrigerator
to my local municipal
transfer station i have to pay a fee
and that fee is reasonable it might be
as much as 25 but it's it's reasonable
but what if the fees to dispose of solar
panels were much much higher
would that discourage people from taking
those solar panels to the transfer
station and would we end up with a bunch
of disposed solar panels in the woods
uh as that's a hypothetical question um
if that scenario were to were to play
out um
you know i would imagine the state would
would
assess that problem as it started to
occur and and deal with it the question
is are we looking for a solution without
having a problem first
now that said
i i do feel that the solar industry writ
large is serious about this problem and
is very open to looking for solutions
proactively before the before the
problem starts to occur i simply think
that we should we should think of a
program that is scaled to meet the
likelihood that a problem
is going to arise
and from my in my sort of
read having having spent a lot of time
paying very close attention to this
industry i'm not convinced the problem
is going to arise i do think the private
industry will step up and provide
solutions before a problem comes to pass
thank you representative mcgee is
recognized for a question
thank you mr chairman
following along on this line of
questioning and some stuff that's come
up already i i think
the heavy-handedness or the the
fulsomeness of what the bill attempts to
do
uh i'll go back to representative kelly
pitt's point that she made earlier
the manufacturers are not in this
country and while business is
international
it appears that there's a lot of
interaction between
the state whoever we put in charge of it
at the state if we hire someone and the
manufacturer remember no speeches
questions well it's based on the bill um
so the bill includes in it
uh
details of how the manufacturer will
interact with the state and if and if
they don't conform to the things that
are in this bill
then they would be prohibited from
functioning in the state so i guess the
question is
uh
manufacturers have to submit a plan and
jump through these hoops and write back
and forth and meet all these hurdles
does that convolute their ability to
work in the state or does it you know
confound the ability for people to
operate as
manufacturers who are selling in the
state because that was my original
question and i'm just curious uh clean
energy new hampshire does does share
these concerns about enforceability uh
and i i would uh i would particularly
think that the department of
environmental services should like to
sound uh have their voice heard on on
how they would imagine they would
enforce this bill um i would also be
interested to reach out to the state of
washington if if in fact that this is
where this language came came from and
asked how their experience has been in
trying to trying to enforce um and
interact with manufacturers that are
that are largely overseas
um
the the
you know
if what we're looking for is a program
that has a lighter footprint
um i would suggest that perhaps some
sort of fee that is levied on either
installers or or customers
might be something that's more
appropriate
and that fee could that if he could fund
some sort of program that um
that would that we could we could work
with the solar installers to try to
determine what what makes sense um i
think that that generally speaking clean
energy new hampshire's concern is with
the bill as written not with the concept
of trying to come up with some sort of
solution for the end of life of solar
panels thank you
representative callie pitts
i love to be controversial
uh
what i
was thinking i'm trying to
get it all together so
forgive me for a minute when i return my
battery i'm the customer so i pay for it
so perhaps
there
should be
a fee on
solar power customers a small fee per
megawatt hour
and electric companies because most of
solar power and correct me if i'm not
wrong
is meant is
net metered
so you really have two customers you
have the the
the homeowner or and i'm thinking small
places because large places are
controlled by the s e c if they're large
farms
uh and the other customer is the power
company because they buy some of it
so
that to me would seem to be a better way
to do this
to establish a fund
for the decommissioning and the
recycling especially if you have to
transport these panels
i would think and and the other question
i had is
we require an electrician to connect
these panels correct
do we require an electrician
to deconnect them
that's right
so to answer the last question first the
answer is yes a licensed and master
electrician is required to to work or
that said because it does say our
license plates live free or die
homeowners are also allowed to do their
own electrical work on their own premise
premises but uh it is either a master
electrician or the homeowner who who uh
does that work
um
you know
i i would suggest if if it was if if you
were asking me my opinion that the most
appropriate way forward with this bill
would be to study the question uh
because because would uh some sort of
fee levied through your utility bill be
a more appropriate way to come up with a
recycling and stewardship plan how much
would that fee need to be what is the
cost of recycling a solar panel what is
the cost of transporting it uh you know
what is the state of the salvage market
these are all questions that that i
think should be answered before a
program is established
follow-up
do you need a follow-up
any additional questions representative
lewicki
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um can you give us
any idea what the actual scrap value is
of the solar panel how many pounds of
aluminum how many pounds of copper how
many pounds of lead you know these are
all materials that have commodity value
and if we could have a feel for that it
might tell us whether it's actually
economical to recycle them as is or not
thank you i i do not have those numbers
at my fingertips um what i can tell you
is that the in terms of the weight of
solar panels most of the weight is glass
and aluminum um the actual the actual uh
you know functional uh pieces of a solar
panel the silicon and the and the metals
uh the conductors that are contained
therein are you know typically less than
25 of the weight of a solar panel so
really what we're talking about is
something that would recycle aluminum
and glass and would and would
deconstruct the panels into their
composite parts and then the question of
how to deal with the heavy metals that
are part of the that are part of the the
system that conducts the electricity
through the panel it's the same the same
way that you that you recycle e-waste
generally and that is that is a
complicated uh and and frankly dirty
process um which i think is highlighted
in in this bill and in representative
plett's testimony um but that said uh
the i i would go back to my my initial
point here which is why are we singling
out this particular uh product when
there is no such stewardship plan for
any other type of e-waste uh and and the
representative did in his own testimony
sen uh uh highlight that this would this
this product is only one percent of the
global uh weight of e-waste that's
produced each year so so
uh that that is simply my question it
seems like this bill is singling out a
specific product and i'm not sure why
no follow-up okay
next up is representative partial
thank you chair vos and uh thank you mr
brown
um my concern is that we can't always
depend on private industry to take
responsibility especially if there's no
profit to be made
we know right now that consumers are
already paying much of the price of
disposal of products right across the
board whether it be plastic bottles or
solar panels
my transfer station in marlboro
uh was funded self-funded by the
overseas sales of plastic china all the
recyclables were going over there now
they've recently stopped buying these
plastics the market's fallen and we now
have to take up the additional cost of
our disposing
and our transfer station as community
um
now could you foresee a similar ferris
question could you foresee a similar
situation
with recycling in solar panels should
the market for the recyclables that are
derived from that fall out and would
have built in
the implied question is a bill like this
be more appropriate in that like
uh
the answer to that question is is yes of
course i think that that there may
eventually be a problem that would need
to be solved the question of uh do we
need to create a program preemptively
before a problem begins to materialize
uh that that is the question before us
today right are we going to create a
program preemptively before problem
materializes uh
i one thing that i would say is that
clean energy new hampshire does not take
a position on um enhanced producer
recyclability did i get that right
responsibility responsibility um
programs um that but but at the bare
minimum such a such a program that
encompasses all the items that go into
our waste stream does have the benefit
of being ideologically consistent as
opposed to singling out individual items
uh from the waste stream and uh so so i
would simply suggest that that if what
what is the problem we are trying to
solve here is the problem how we manage
our waste streams if so it seems that
the bill should be written differently
um if the problem is the the amount of
solar panels going into landfills today
i would suggest we don't really have a
problem yet
thank you and i did have a second
question but i think you answered it so
thank you both okay thank you
representative manners no okay
representative thomas did you have
another question uh thank you miss chair
i i think it may have been an answer but
i'll ask it any different way
because of
transportation accidents faulty panels
i'm sure
there have been um panels that had to be
disposed right now
how is that handled right now and is it
is it just purely landfilled or as is or
do they break the glass up and segregate
how is it handled now the the answer to
that question is
is that i don't have the numbers to
answer with with great precision but i
can tell you that uh all of the above do
occur i'm certain that there are panels
that have wound up in landfills i am
certain that there are panels in the
united states that have been recycled
into their composite parts what i do not
know and can i answer for you today is
what percentage of each practice has
happened
follow up
thank you mr thanks for follow-up so
for the ones that are currently in
landfill now do you foresee
a future not in the two distant
future where they will discover that
those landfills will become
toxic like the super sites
uh again uh the the if the question is
uh is the volume of solar panels being
disposed of in our landfills creating
for instance uh groundwater problems is
a broader question um and i would i
would also add that it's a question that
is not confined simply to the disposal
of solar panels but also uh i i know for
a fact that uh double a batteries go
into the go into landfills all the time
even though they shouldn't and the same
the same problem applies to whenever
that happens and so that is a broader
question of our solid waste management
and if what if that's what we're
concerned about there should be a
broader program of how we approach solid
waste management including uh you know
ensuring the integrity of the lining of
landfills and their caps and all the
other things that the department of
environmental services is
charged with
thank you
thank you uh looking for additional
questions from mr evans brown
seeing none i thank you mr evans brown
for your testimony we appreciate you
coming here today and uh giving us your
perspective thank you very much
um
well it's 10 22.
and we're done nobody else has signed up
to speak on this bill
and
i have not scheduled another bill until
12 30. so we're going to have a
lengthy lunch break today
unless anybody has
something that they would like to
discuss before we break for lunch
in which case representative mick
williams is recognized
thank you chair votes i wanted to ask
about working in subcommittees for this
committee um will we be assigning any
folks especially for the early bills to
do some working committees i've noticed
that as our scheduling
for the last couple of hearings we've
had some openings that perhaps could
have been an opportunity for a
subcommittee to get together and i'm
hoping we could maybe talk about that
well that's a good question
i don't know if you were here earlier we
did establish a subcommittee earlier
today for house bill 1644 the 5g bill
and that committee will be meeting on
monday
we have not established any
subcommittees for any other bills
i am scheduling an exact session for our
five early bills on monday february 7th
we will complete the public hearing on
hb 1644 at one o'clock
on february 7th and then at 2 o'clock on
february 7th
we will
start an executive session on the five
early bills
of which hb 1644 is won
so
if anybody sees any need for a
subcommittee on the other four bills
that are targeted for that executive
session please
let me know
right away
so that we can think about whether or
not we should form such a said committee
representative mcgee thank you mr
chairman um
the four bills that you're talking about
we have i think five fn bills so which
ones specifically are they from
1 11 or 1
18 or
yeah but that would be the fns right or
well interestingly uh
informed me that five of our bills were
early bills
and there were a couple that had an fn
after them that weren't on that list so
i can't tell you
what the criteria they use for
determining what's an early bill and
what isn't
is
i did send an email earlier today to
our admin gary morris about setting up
the
exec session for february 7th i've got
to go talk to her about adding the
continuation of
the public hearing on hb14 1644 to that
list but um
i can if you want to go with me we can
go over there and and
quickly identify what the other four
bills were
off the top of my head they were
the bill that establishes a
concert climate conservation corps
commission okay um
yeah i'm i'm not dredging it up from my
memory exactly what four they were but
they're they're the bills that i talked
about at the beginning of our session as
being early bills that have to be done
by february 17th
and just last week we're informed that
we have to move that date up to february
10th
because
the speaker had to schedule a house
session the week of february 14th which
means it will likely be on the 17th
so
in order to get those bills done by the
10th we have to have this exact session
on february 7th yep
again my brent's not working too well on
the seventh and does that mean we have a
free morning
and can we use some of that for
discussion time on the bill i mean you
said one o'clock you're gonna schedule
the end of the public hearing and two
o'clock the executive session
what's the plan for the morning
there is no plan for the morning at the
moment
so
but you're right that time is available
and if we see the need as a committee to
schedule some
a work session for that for that period
of time we can do that
that's why i raised the issue to discuss
do we need any more subcommittee work
sessions on those five bills
representative mcgee i would very much
like to have time to work with
representative platt on 1459 to discuss
some of the issues that were raised
today
that's not an early bill you're right
but i'm just saying if we have a work
session or if we have time where we can
put in bills that we'd like to discuss
further my interpretation is that this
is not an early bill because it's
effective date
uh is so far in the in the future so
that's why i guess the clerk decided it
didn't need to be an early bill
but certainly i'm not opposed to setting
up
a subcommittee for this bill
i don't know that it needs to be done on
february 7th
or before that but we do need to have a
probably have a subcommittee for this
bill eventually yes
representative platt
i'd be interested in what the
representatives think uh it needs
tweaking in the bill frankly i thought
it was well written i want to present it
as is but if somebody if there's an
overwhelming desire to change it in some
way
i'll listen
i'll allow representative mcgee to
answer that question yeah i would just
say i think it is very well written i i
think what i'm concerned about is if
it's going to produce the desired
outcomes and i think there are some
issues to talk through in terms of
whether
um
what we're trying to get in terms of the
the goal
is actually going to be achieved by the
bill
i think callie pits yeah i think that
that bill
two hours ago i said i thought it needed
to be a study committee
i think it needs to be a study
commission and i i would want to work
with
representative
on perhaps doing that
so that the next session you could come
up with some
really positive details and some
information
i
the more i think about it the more
questions that were raised i think we
need to really work on answering some of
those
not that the bill isn't well written not
that cia that washington state doesn't
have some good ideas
but i i really think we have to
call it into new hampshire
and i really think we need to look at
the issues that were raised
okay thank you for that input why don't
we do this
anybody who's interested in serving on a
subcommittee
on hb 1469 the solar recycling bill
please send me an email
and once uh
i get
let's let's i put a should put a
deadline on this send me an email by a
week from
today
which would be february february 1st
and once i have that information i will
determine if there are enough
interested persons to form a study
committee or a
subcommittee and if so we'll form one
how's that
acceptable
okay any other issues representative
mann thank you mr mr chairman i'm my
concern is um
i think we ought to
get an understanding of the details of
recycling
a lot of early recycling parts like
taking off the aluminum and the copper
should be quite easy but
some of the later steps
so
if we could understand how the industry
would actually the recycling industry
would actually work
it might actually be helpful to inform
our legislation
um
there needs to be also some financial
incentive for the recycling to take
place and of course that's what this
bill is about but
as i said earlier perhaps the person the
company is replacing a solar panel which
is the most likely
reason to
might be
[Music]
by requiring them to
supervise the recycling or make sure
that it's done properly that might be
useful
it's just a thought that would be
that would be part of the study
committee that's being recommended now
thank you
thank you for your thoughts on that i've
i've done some reading about recycling
of solar panels and the reading i've
done is suggested
that the cost to recycle a solar panel
exceeds the value of the materials you
you derive from that recycling process
so it would seem on the surface
to be uneconomic to recycle recycle a
solar panel but
that's something we should investigate
in in detail
and i think this bill is is
less concerned with recycling solar
panels than it is
in protecting new hampshire
municipalities from having to deal with
unexpected costs
when
solar panels show up on their doorstep
representative thomas
thank you mr chair um it's interesting
on the entire conversation with um
1469 and all the other items they were
mentioned about being recycled
that
what was interesting was wind turbines
were never brought up
and so i might
suggest that if the committee decides
they want to expand the bill and i'm not
saying they should but if they do
wind turbines should play
a major factor if they don't already
that
is a legitimate point most wind farms
are
large enough that they are
governed by the rules of the site
evaluation committee which requires
decommissioning
as part of the
the overall project plan and its cost
but it is something we should look at
because there may be especially going
forward
it may be possible for an individual
homeowner to
put a a wind turbine in his backyard and
generate electricity so it might be
worthwhile considering how to deal with
the waste generated by recycling one of
those
okay any any other comments before we
seeing none
i will recess
this
this meeting today until 12 30 at which
time
we will hear
house bill 1628
directing the department of energy to
generate a report on the micro grid
project currently in progress at the
university of new hampshire in
collaboration with regional utilities so
you
okay good afternoon everyone let's
resume the
science technology and energy committee
session for january 25th
2022 this afternoon we have five bills
and we'll be starting with house bill
1628-f
n
i would just like to remind
committee members
if you arrived late
there's a sign in sheet
make sure you sign it before you leave
today to verify that you were here to
attend at least part of the public
hearing
and i would also remind everyone that
when you are recognized to speak be sure
to turn your microphone on
and once you finish speaking turn your
microphone off
depending on how many pink cards we get
um and by the way i'll remind everyone
if you want to speak on this bill
you need to
submit a pink card to do so
and depending on how many
pink cards we get
we may limit
committee members to just two questions
per person testifying per per
presenter we also may limit presenters
uh the amount of time that presenters
have to present representative callie
pitts did you have a question yes for
the chair did you get the list of the
i didn't was i supposed to do that i
thought you were going to get that at
lunch time
i'll see if i can run out and get that
from ms morris
after we get started here
okay
so we have two people signed up to speak
on this bill
in addition to the
prime sponsor
so i'd like to recognize now the prime
sponsor representative samsich
thank you mr chairman
um for the record uh peter somsich
rockingham 27 portsmouth
um
i'm
i'm the sponsor of hp 1628 however i am
submitting a an amendment which replaces
that entirely
and i'll explain why it replaces it but
um
i've handed out a copy of that amendment
to 1628
so the original intent of my bill had
been
that since there was a
microgrid project being developed by the
un university new hampshire and
eversource
uh as well as i think unitil
uh i wanted us to have some type of a
report or documentation about that
about that project uh to guide us with
looking at other possibilities for
microgrades
however i was
informed with conversations from
tom cronin of unh and from donna gamache
of eversource that in fact
there are
this is not the only microgrid uh in
progress and in fact some businesses
already have their own separate
microgrids
in the state that unh is aware of and so
um
they asked me to broaden my bill
to not just focus on the project at unh
and
and the one with eversource and unh but
also to
focus on trying to accumulate a report
that in fact inventories
the current
projects that have been in place already
and are or are being developed right now
in new hampshire and put a report like
that together by november first so we
have a more comprehensive look at what's
going on in new hampshire and we just
don't focus on one single project which
incidentally has stalled for a very
variety of reasons and i'm sure some of
the testimony we'll hear after me will
explain
so that was the motivation behind this
and
that's all really i have to say about it
but i'm willing to take any questions i
can answer right now and i'm sure some
of the people
behind me who will be testifying will
give more details about that
okay thank you representative samson for
that bill introduction are there any
questions representative thomas is
recognized thank you mr chair thank you
for taking my question i guess the
including unh but perhaps other
areas that have microgrids
do they do they not have reports that
they are doing at least internally
as to how their microgrids are doing
have did you ask them or look into
whether they would have some some
reports generated
within themselves
thank you for the question uh represent
thomas uh i
i was not aware of businesses that were
doing this
until a couple days ago until unh
contacted me about it
and um they were the ones who said they
know of several businesses who are doing
this
and i'm sure there's an internal report
about it at the at the companies
involved i just didn't have any kind of
any link yet with the companies to find
out more about it and i thought this
report would be an ideal way of
gathering that information in one report
together from all the sites in new
hampshire so i i think some people who
will testify after me will talk about
that very issue
okay i'll look forward to that thank you
okay thank you any other questions
representative callie pitts
do microgrids have to be
registered or licensed or approved by
um thank you uh representative calpis
i i'm not exactly sure what how that's
done but my understanding is that since
the utility has to be involved there has
to be some approval process that lets
the utility work with an entity to
create a microgrid
as part of the puc process but
i'm not sure about the details how that
works i'm sure you just can't do it on
your own
now you could do i guess you could do a
microgrid that doesn't connect to the
main grid if it's just your internal use
and that's kind of what i'd like to know
how these businesses are doing it versus
like a public entity like unh would be
doing it with eversource and they were
doing it with unitil as well so they're
doing the gas utility electric utility
and the campus
and so that's a much bigger entity
but i'm not aware what the process is
but i'm sure there's some type of
regulation or registration of that
process before you can go ahead with it
follow up
my point of the question was would the
utilities
excuse me have the information
that we're seeking and have if they do
could we ask them to
relate it to us so if they have
helped in the process of creating some
of these microgrids i'm sure that they
would have
some of that information that's all
thank you yeah thank you that my initial
uh
intention of the initial bill was to get
that information about the unh project
from eversource and from the unh
and uh but they made me aware that
there's more out there than just that
one project
okay ms gamache has signed up to testify
for eversource so i'm sure she'll have
additional information to supply
any additional questions for
representative samsich
seeing none i thank you uh
my honorable colleague for your bill
introduction
on griffin
roberge from the department of energy
who has signed up to testify for two
thank you mr chairman and members of the
committee for the record uh griffin
roberge from the new hampshire
department of energy
here to testify in a neutral position on
house bill 1628 um unfortunately i can't
speak substantially to the amendment as
i'm only just now seeing it
so i can't really give a lot of feedback
on that until i have a chance to kind of
review it with other staff and
provide some feedback on it which i'm
more than willing to do at a later date
uh v yeah gotta write sorry via email um
in regards to
uh house bill
1628 fn as introduced
the department outlaw outlined um
some
some observations in the fiscal note
specifically on lines 19 and 20
where it requires the department of
energy to
generate a report describing new
hampshire communities where a micro grid
project may have the greatest impact
i i you know based on the fiscal note it
said that a lot of of what was required
under this previous report could be
accomplished by existing staff and
funding but that
sentence on lines 19 and 20 was a little
bit broad
i guess the phrase greatest impact is
not defined so
are we talking about reduction of
greenhouse gas emissions reduction in
electric costs
that would need to be flushed out but
again you know that's a previous version
of the bill
um
in terms of microgrids currently in the
state and i know
donna gamache is behind me she can
certainly correct anything i have to say
but
i know there is an ongoing docket at the
19057 if anyone's interested um in part
of that docket um eversource proposed um
two projects as part of a uh
it's part of a grid transformation
transformation and enablement program
and one of those is obviously the unh
project
uh for the purposes of this it's the
oyster river
clean innovation project
after talking with tom france who's the
director of regulatory support at the
department um
eversource and unh are no longer
pursuing this project
at unh
for a variety of reasons
in my shorthand conversations with unh
staffing funding issues that type of
thing are the greatest concern for them
right now
mr director france also reached out to
other regulated utilities in the state
to see if they have any active micro
grid projects currently in existence
and as of just a few moments ago i we
heard back from liberty unitel and
eversource and to the best of our
knowledge
there aren't any active microgrid
projects in the state that they're aware
of
at least under
eversource's proposal they
um
in this dock at 19057 they intended to
take out these two projects from the
docket and then submit it to puc for
review and approval in a separate docket
however
no docket has been filed to date again
because unh is no longer pursuing the
project
willing to answer any questions that the
committee might have but again um any
questions relevant to the amendment that
couldn't answer more than willing to
provide an email with
uh written comments at a later time
thank you thank you mr roberge for
your always excellent testimony i do
have one quick question
the
fiscal note that's attached to the copy
of the bill i have
basically says nothing it says
we couldn't do anything
and they said that they would
forward a completed fiscal note to the
house clerk's office do you know if
there has been i have a i have an um i
have a
fiscal note revised as of january 19th
um
i don't know if it's available over
there i i can i can check for you if you
like but uh i at least have a i at least
have a revised fiscal note as of january
19. thank you kristen is there a revised
physical note attached to the bills over
okay thank you for looking i appreciate
that if the committee would like i can
forward it to the committee after please
send it to our uh
our alias email alias appreciate that
are there any other questions uh for
i i wanted to know do you know if all
mike any and all microgrids in the state
are subject to regulation
you know
going off of your last question as to
whether or not they they
receive puc review and approval i assume
utilities when they're pursuing a
project like that would like to
engage in cost recovery in which case
yes it would be subject to puc review
and approval
man follow-up follow-up would that
include
private businesses i couldn't answer
that definitively i can certainly check
but you know to the extent you know that
say utility worked to the private
business to develop its own micro grid
project i'm assuming
you know a utility might want to pursue
cost recovery of that but i can
certainly look into that thank you for
being private businesses thank you
representative plett is recognized
thank you thank you for taking my
question did i understand you to say
there are no active
microgrid
grid projects being pursued anywhere in
new hampshire
again i can't predict what the future
might say but again based on
correspondence that uh the the
department has had with uh three
regulated utilities in the state liberty
unitel eversource um they are not aware
of any microgrid projects currently in
existence in there and is still
premature
my question
uh okay
i guess that was a follow-up but you
don't need to answer it
representative mcgee is recognized thank
you mr chair and thank you mr robert
nice to see you again good to see you um
so when you
talked about the bill and doe's position
or non-position you know looking at the
bill you mentioned
uh two different items that you were
unsure whether the bill was asking of
doe because it was kind of vague and you
said you know are you looking at
lowering emissions or are you looking at
costs yep um
and i think the thing that i would bring
up that i think doe would be helpful in
especially if there aren't any active
plans going on right now
is the idea of resiliency which is i
think the point of microgrids is to have
some sort of self-sufficiency
and for different areas and businesses
or towns to have some ability to take
care of their own energy needs in case
of something going wrong so i think
that's probably where that vague thing
was going so i i don't know if the
department has had any discussions
around the role of microgrids or
whether there should be any role for the
department energy of energy in trying to
look at whether
microgrids make sense in parts of new
hampshire sure and and that's something
i'm
certain could be studied or something
like that but in terms of i guess the
specific concerns on lines 19 to 20
again it's just greatest impact
departments i think is the committee
well know love as much clarity as
possible so um you know getting some
specificity to that as to specifically
what the department is looking at what
the legislature would like to see in
terms of greatest impact would be
welcomed but again that's in the as
introduced version of the bill and again
i'd like to you know welcome the
opportunity to comment more definitively
on the amendment after i have a chance
okay uh any additional questions for
yes representative lewicki
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question this is
uh looking for information but do we
know how many uh base
how many people who are just off grid
that have a significant grid of their
own is this a knowable thing
and how do we define the difference
between off grid and microgrid micro
good i would assume means it will be
connected to the main grid some of the
time yeah sure so a micro grid is
basically a group of say interconnected
loads and distribute energy resources
your battery storage your solar that can
kind of flip on and off the grid
when necessary or at will
as representative mcgee noted you know
there have been
discussions that microgrids might be
beneficial to
deploy these distributed energy
resources and also improve resiliency
and that type of thing and to also kind
of be a
a modified way of addressing issues in
the distribution system say if there's
an outage or something like that to
redirect resources elsewhere um in terms
of your specific question in terms of
tallying you know individual homeowners
or specific businesses that may may or
may not be off the grid
i i couldn't answer that definitively at
this time
again you know going back to what was
being proposed in the docket between
eversource and unh you know that was
something that came but came through for
uh cost recovery in a in a docket um you
know
in terms of what a private business or a
private residence might do with power
that they're generating on site i can't
speak to that definitively but i can
certainly you know dig a little bit more
into that and get you a more substantial
answer
okay
any more questions for mr roberge
seeing none uh thank you mr roberge for
your testimony thank you and i will next
call on miss donna gamash from
eversource
please turn on the microphone
sorry
for the record donna gamache with
eversource energy thank you very much
for um uh hearing my testimony today
i just wanted to speak to this our
situation with unh and why um it no
longer is a pro it's no longer viable
for us at the moment
originally the project was intended to
be a pilot so that we could learn some
lessons from it where the weaknesses
were some barriers challenges
and what we were going to do originally
unh was the perfect place because if you
think you know to the questions that
we've heard before why would you even
have a microgrid and really in our minds
the microgrid would be to be helpful in
a certain geographic area when you have
a a storm an outage for some various
lengths of time
and unh obviously is like a little
community where folks could go for
shelter
but you would also so you would make
sure that you had isolated that area
whatever that geographic area is and you
had enough energy to just keep the
critical facilities open and you could
have folks go for shelter for as long a
period as possible
so unh was perfect at the time because
they have roughly 13 megawatts of
existing generations assets owned by unh
and um griffin was correct
when he was talking generally about
microgrid you abs you have to that
generation helps
them in their existing needs but if
you're going to use it as a microgrid
you have to augment that generation so
we were going to add some solar and it
was roughly five megawatts of solar plus
some conservation
and the and we were going to island the
school during whatever outage you know
duration it was as well as serving a
portion of the town of durham so by the
way the town of durham was also a
partner in this
um
and the critical facilities that we were
going to ensure would continue to
operate was their wastewater treatment
plant police and fire departments and
their town halls as well as the
university
we found very soon that we were bumping
into some challenges first off covet hit
and that
griffin spoke to what unh said about
their challenges their resources took a
big hit not entirely because of covet
but that played a big role in it
this the resources became scarce in
order to keep moving forward but beyond
that the other challenges were
basically the costs
um to your point representative cali
pits if a utility is engaged in any way
and the utility is going to have to
recover costs we do have to get public
utility permission we have our regulator
has to approve it we have to make our
case
and um
ultimately
what we found was there are certain high
costs associated with it we in this
particular plan we never intended to own
the solar so we assumed in the cost of
this that there would be another third
party that owned the solar so we did not
include that but we found in terms of
some of the distribution requirements
there were costs associated there
and
and the storage it also included storage
and there were costs associated with the
storage so in early discussions with our
regulators we realized that we were
going to have to try to come up with
some grants to allow us to move forward
to learn the lessons that this could
provide us
for the state generally but buy down
some of those higher costs and so we
spent a great deal of time and resources
trying to actively get some federal
grants to buy it down and we found that
to be very challenging those grants are
not
um
suited very well for something like this
so
um as we were going to continue down
that path but what we quickly bumped
into was that
representative mcgee you did say the
purpose is resiliency
and you're correct you're quite right so
we would have to bring to the public
utilities commission a really
appropriate cost-benefit analysis that
showed that the benefits outweighed the
cost
and one of the benefits is resiliency
but you have to be able to monetize that
benefit and it we found no place in the
nation where there is a an analysis that
allows us to be able to monetize that
so it was going to be a bigger challenge
now i also checked with our team to find
out okay where else in our service
territory do we have microgrids because
i have heard about them in the past and
we have several in connecticut not all
of them uh are part of you know that
connected with us but um connecticut
started initiative to move forward with
microgrids in 2011 2012 time period
after they're very serious i think it
was super storm sandy they decided that
they had to take matters into their own
hands that changes the cost benefit
analysis enough that maybe not having
that resiliency analysis would was okay
in massachusetts um we do have
microgrids there um on the military some
of the military bases i don't know but
the military covering the cost of those
and obviously for reasons other than uh
you know national security the cost
benefit analysis takes there's a little
different approach there we um have
worked on feasibility for about 20 other
projects in
in massachusetts as well but so far none
of those have come to fruition yet but i
my i don't know if they're all still on
the table or not but
anyway in a in a nutshell that's the
issue that happened to us we did
appreciate the time that we did work
with unh and with the town of durham uh
they were and unitil uh they were very
very um good partners and um hopefully
uh there is what i did learn is that
there is a um
i'm trying to remember the name of it
there is a group uh that is trying to
put together some short-term and
long-term analysis of how you can
quantify the benefits of resiliency
so they're actively working that now so
hopefully soon we'll see we'll see an
outcome of that
thank you
okay thank you for that testimony
let me
typing catch up first there i'm all set
up this was a pilot
being a pilot you don't necessarily have
to prove
beforehand that the benefit is there
you're learning from it is that so
i don't know how to answer that exactly
i would have to talk to our regulatory
folks but i do know that originally
we wanted this to be part of our rate
case and we agreed to take it out of the
rate case and file something separately
as griffin referred to
so that we could um
basically get into more of the
nitty-gritty on it i don't know if we
were going to move forward with that
case before during and after or just
after i'm i'm sorry i don't have the
answer but i could check follow up
please follow up um
i thought you did have a micro grid
my memory's escaping me chester field i
think was an area that was really weak
with transmission and so you're putting
a
in combination with the transmission to
uh keep that system alive is that so are
you aware of that well if if that's the
case i don't think we called it or we
may not have used the term microgrid
with that we may have had a mobile
substation or something that we put in
place and i mean
i guess it's terminology but i my my
recollection was a mobile
substation
thank you thank you representative
thomas is recognized thank you mr chair
thank you for taking my question i'm i'm
curious since you mentioned
massachusetts about some military bases
uh having microgrids i'm wondering if
one of them was hanscom air force base
and the reason why i'm asking the
question is because just a few days ago
hanscom lost total power on their base
so i was just curious and and if you
could explain how you know
if if you know those things how how
they're doing
i could i could dig a little more for
you i didn't i don't have that
information handy but i can do that for
you i'll get that right thank you you're
welcome
additional questions representative
berezni is recognized
thank you for taking my question uh you
mentioned that the military has
a cost-benefit analysis
from a resiliency standpoint is that
something you you've looked at and
does any of that make sense for for new
hampshire for non-military purpose but
still for resiliency thank you
you're welcome i i don't i don't think
it applies exactly because their needs
and what their um
what they're trying to protect against
is different than just outages and
resiliency like we are there for them
it's a national security issue as well
so i think that cost benefit analysis
would be very skewed differently than if
we would apply it here but i i could do
my best to see if i could find out what
that is i'm not sure that i'll be able
to get all that info but i can do my
best to find out what their analysis is
okay thank you you're welcome
okay
next up is representative callie pitts
thank you donna if i had a
complex
maybe five buildings say hospital
buildings
and i said i do not want to be re i
don't want to be relying on the power
in an outage or whatever and i wanted to
go on my own
and generate even my own internal power
see i i i i'm i'm having a problem here
with
i think i think the issue is for a micro
grid is that it's for a
a geographic area and if you if it was
for in if it was for personal use i
think they probably might call that
self-generation even if it was temporary
people who have generators during storms
don't think it would fit the category of
a microgrid but i would double check
what i'm saying to you
i will double check
follow-up but my follow-up would be so
we we worry about resiliency and i worry
about
that particular
are there any situations where there are
places like that
where there are say complexes or
industrial complexes that generate and
provide their own electricity without
having the monica
micro microgrid i see your question now
um my my understanding is that there are
very many facilities in new york in
anywhere actually but they that do have
backup generation i can tell you every
source in manchester we have we have
we we have to keep running because we
have to
no matter what so we do have backup
generation that flips on
i'm quite sure there are many critical
hospitals who have that
i know that there are some other
businesses who have it i don't think
it's up to me to say who they are but i
do know there are some critical
businesses who have it
thank you uh additional questions for ms
gamache
representative creation
thank you chair thank you for taking my
question um so that last question made
me think of a different one is there
a different advantage to a microgrid in
terms of resiliency as opposed to just
having backup generation can you speak
to the the differences between those two
things yeah so the real i mean it set
aside what we were trying to do with unh
um but when the idea of microgrids first
started to to gain popularity it was
because let's just say if you take the
city of manchester and there's going to
be an outage and it's out for a while
enough that you're
you want to make sure that people have a
place to go to get food gas shelter so
you might have a grocery store you would
find a geographic region where people
can go to a grocery store or mall to
stay warm
in between they can get gas to keep
their car so if they had to get some
place they could get to the doctors and
get food and so the whole idea of a
microgrid was to make sure that there
was an area you wouldn't you wouldn't
have to worry about taking the entire it
would take too long to get the whole
city up but if you could make sure that
there was a microgrid that you could
turn on where you you knew that people
would be safe that would be the whole
purpose
seeing none i thank
representative notter thank you mr
chairman um thank you for taking the
question you just got the wheels turning
because you said
what you just said
made me wonder if there is a microgrid
to
to power up one little small area
would that
make
getting the power back on everywhere
else delayed because they don't really
need to because they're okay for now
it wouldn't change
we have very strict
requirements about how we restore power
it would not change any of those
requirements it would just it would just
ensure that that people had a place to
go while we continued to do what we did
okay thank you
any
last minute questions okay
representative callie pitts i'll
i don't remember the year but it was a
few years ago when we had the ice storm
and there were people without power for
two weeks
did we have
micro grids or these self-contained
areas then and have we proliferated them
since
so in the ice storm of 08 that was
really groundbreaking for us in so many
ways
yes it was 14 days in
some areas some areas we got on before
that
i don't believe we had any microgrids in
new hampshire i don't think we have any
now isle of shoals is basically an
a microgrid
but outside of that
we didn't have any at the time but the
one thing that we did do then
and i don't know i can't speak to how
that fits into what we do today but we
did try working with local officials
to
prioritize whether it was a school
in an area where people could go for
shelter because they could they could
they could um shelter more people than a
typical shelter and they could also
provide food and so we would prioritize
certain areas and at the time in 20 that
was 2008
i do remember that there were some key
officials some key legislators
governor's offices who wanted to come
and tour to make sure that we were
actually doing the right thing and that
it made sense and that we weren't
slowing up the rest of the restoration
by doing it so um and we had to and the
puc um did a a an intensive study of how
we there is a report that the puc put
out after that um you know lessons
learned what we could do better it was
the first time and it sure was a it was
a learning curve for all of us so um
there that that report i see if i i
don't know if i have any around
but and shortly right after that we had
snow tober so we went from the ice storm
of 08 then into snowtober where we were
i don't know just under two weeks
without power so they just started to
come rapidly but those lessons learned
brought us to the point where we
we are trying to look uh you know more
steadily at how we can find microgrids
that are less costly
okay thank you i have a quick question
is it true that an essential component
of a microgrid is
generation within the microgrid correct
you absolutely have to have generation
connecticut their focus has always been
on fuel cells for that generation
they've branched out from that as well
but when connecticut first started
looking at microgrids their fuel of
choice their generation of choice was
using fuel cells so yes absolutely they
have to have a source of generation
which was why unh was so perfect because
they have
existing generation and then we just
augmented it
wouldn't have augmented it
representative plett did you have
another question i did
uh since restructuring uh distribution
companies are generally prohibited from
owning generation but are there
exceptions for things like microgrids
there is an exception
to that prohibition and it falls under
374 g i believe it's 374 g
and it
for each utility you we can have it's
like a clean energy um
generation
but it and whatever clean there's a
certain criteria for clean energy and
it's up to a certain percent of our peak
load and i
i don't know what it is today but at the
time i think we saw it would be you know
generally up to like five megawatts i
don't know if that still exists today
when we first started talking about it
um
but for that you still have to go to the
public utilities commission and get
approval
and um
i don't think that any util i could be
wrong but i think any utility has gotten
that approval yet i don't think anybody
i think only one utility has gone before
the puc for that approval i don't think
representative harrington has a
oh
okay
seeing none i thank you ms gamache for
your testimony
and having no additional pink cards for
this
for this bill
i will close the public hearing on
house bill
28 dash
fn
we will open a public hearing on house
bill 1250
i was asked to retrieve the number the
bill numbers for the exec session that
we'll have on february 7th
the five bills that we will exact that
day will be house bill 1419
[Music]
house bill
1506 house bill 1601
house bill 1621
and house bill
1644.
all five of those bills are early bills
and so we have to complete them by
february 10th so we will
exec them on monday february 7th
starting at 2 o'clock
and prior to that at 1 o'clock we'll
finish the public hearing on house bill
so are there any other questions about
seeing none
we are
you
it being 1 30 i would like to call to
order the public hearing on house bill
a bill requiring the public utilities
commission to consider climate change
and making rate-setting decisions
the prime sponsor of this bill is
representative gallagher of merrimack
with representative oxenom
of solomon county as a co-sponsor
neither of them could appear apparently
for this hearing today so i have asked
representative mcgee to introduce this
bill representative mcgee the floor is
yours thank you mr chairman
okay so uh hb 1250 is as the chairman
stated it's a very simple bill in terms
of the letters
um
i'm sorry in terms of the language that
is being added to the existing statute
on fixing of rates by the public
utilities commission and what it does is
it adds bolded language
that basically asks that
if a decision
is up for consideration for rates fees
or just changes
in in the rate setting that they
in looking at that take into
consideration the impact
on of climate change it says on climate
change
so i'm actually you know it's not my
bill so i'm not really sure why it says
after taking into consideration their
impact on climate change
okay
my i think my understanding from reading
the bill is
i'm not sure what representative
gallagher's uh purpose was but i think
that the impetus may have been some of
the changes that have been requested in
the last
uh oh is representative gallagher here
would you like to speak to your bill
can i do that mr chairman
that would be helpful
great
representative gallagher i would remind
you that you do need to fill out a pink
card eventually not right this second
but eventually
but you can take over the bill
introduction and uh we thank you for
being here and thank you representative
mcgee for
so
hi i'm
representative eric gallagher
from
uh merrimack county district 15.
so
and
i live in
a
pretty tall apartment building
in downtown concord and
our laundry room is on the top floor
it has these really big windows in it so
whenever i go up to laundry
look out around the surrounding
countryside
and to the south
there's this
giant smokestack
from the power beau power plant
which
especially this time of year
a giant smoke plume or steam plume
coming out of it and just whenever i see
that
i'm reminded about the
amount of
carbon emissions that
dirty power plants
put
into the air
um and
it um it makes me want to
do something about that
so
i've just been thinking about
what i can do about climate change
so
um
as
as a freshman representative i'm still
kind of new to this um
and
um
what what bodies are there out there
that
uh that
regulate our electrical system the first
two that came to mind
were the site evaluation commission and
the public utilities commission at first
i thought the former was part of the
latter but then i learned that it wasn't
actually so i removed the part about the
site evaluation committee from the bill
but um
that work might be worth
exploring later um
so
um
yeah i want um
i want to do something
pretty simple at first um talking with
some other people
um
there are some
suggestions for
for getting into more details with
numbers and stuff but
um i wasn't quite sure how to
reconcile all of the
suggestions that i was receiving
so
in the end i
just
simple one-liner of
having the public utilities commission
take into consideration
the impact of climate change that
certain
so
the idea is that
cleaner energy should be cheaper
and
dirtier energy should be more expensive
so
that's
that's what i've got for
this legislation so far um
i i believe um
there may be some amendments
forthcoming but
um
oh yeah i guess i'll take questions at
this time
okay thank you representative gallagher
for
having the courage as a freshman to
come forward and
introduce this bill uh representative
harrington has a question for you uh
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question uh in reading the
bill
that you you'll see in there obviously
the terms unjust and unreasonable i
mentioned a number of times these two
terms have years of uh
legal precedent establishing what that
means and there's all sorts of
yardsticks that can be used to judge
that
now this bill would bring in a totally
new
uh concept
taking into consideration their impact
on climate change i mean you could say
i consider this to have impact on
climate change is that sufficient
there's nothing here that tells the puc
and i say this as a former commissioner
what they're supposed to do other than
to consider it they can consider it by
saying well i read a report that
somebody said about that this will have
an impact on climate change but but what
do they do with it so it can you define
a little bit clearer as to what that
term taking into consideration of the
impact on climate change means and
explain how the puc would be able to
implement it
um
so
as for the
unjust and unreasonable parts i don't
think this
really
conflicts with that since
um
climate change is often itself framed as
uh justice issue um
you know
consigning
consigning our future generations to a
worse world
a more uninhabitable world than we
is being unjust to them
so i i think that's perfectly within
keeping with the um
existing
unjust and unreasonable part
and
s4
so as for um
how exactly um
the public utilities
commission is supposed to
um
implement it um
i i see this kind of just as a building
block
or a starting point for which the um
more complicated details of how exactly
they're supposed to determine
um
to how to calculate those
but
you you can't really start
getting more into the details until you
have at least got like just the base
okay any follow-up representative
no thank you mr jimmy representative
kelly pix is recognized
thank you for appearing
i've been in usc freshman
let i'm going to ask you if i'm
interpreting what you're saying
correctly
and again i'm old so my brain doesn't
work so good
you are trying to what i believe that
you are trying to say is that if you
look if if somebody went in and looked
for a rate case
and the reason was that a polluting
plant
in your case you would think it would be
bo
was costing too much
more much more to operate than they
thought it would and they're looking for
some compensation from the puc that the
puc should look into it and say
that plant is contributing
to pollution
and therefore we are not going to give
you the increase that you request or
we're going to minimize the increase
is that what you're trying to say
yeah that's um that sounds about right
yeah
thank you
representative platt has a question
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my
question representative gallagher
are you aware since
the late 90s 2000 roughly that the
industry was deregulated so
utilities distribution utilities no
longer own generation at all
the generation is not regulated
and that uh
therefore the puc has no jurisdiction
over climate change because it's dealing
with transmission and distribution
solely
well
all right if if that's the case then
um
which
which body is there that exists that
could do this because it seems like any
other body get that gets suggested it
seems that that gets shut down shot down
as no that one can't do it either
so i think we've got to
if
i i think climate change is really a
holistic issue that needs to be
thought about in terms of everything we
that
starting with the public utilities
commission
is just a good place to start
you need a follow-up no i think
sufficient okay thank you
representative samsich is recognized
thank you mr chairman and thank you
i i totally sympathize with the
sentiments you have
and while it's true that the public
utilities commission currently
does not take
uh climate change into consideration
i don't think there's any reason why we
couldn't insist that they do
the question is how do we do it
for example if this bill said
look more favorably on rate setting when
it's a co2
reduction of emissions from a fuel or no
emissions from a fuel
that that would be a way of biasing
their decisions for rate setting when
there is no emission is that
i i think that's your goal right you're
you're trying to get the climate change
issue here and um yeah um and originally
like in terms of my own um my own
language that i was drafting it did it
did actually include language like that
but it looks like it just didn't
make it into what ols sent back to me so
um yeah if you'd like to help me
draft an amendment
to make that change i would be open to
it
follow-up chairman thank you
uh
and
uh i i wonder if you're also aware that
the bow plant that you're talking about
operates
of just a tiny fraction of a percent of
the year
when it's when there's nothing else
available so to speak in the winter or
somewhere else
so that if in fact other sources come
that are less polluting
there'd be no reason to turn it on at
all are you aware of that
well
wait could you repeat the last part of
it again
easier to turn on at all or no reason to
turn on at all no what i'm saying is is
right now it is rarely turned on to
operate because there are other sources
and
if in fact
less emitting sources come online or
utilized there would be no reason for
that plant to turn on at all
are you aware of that um
well
i yeah i think
that
that's a good
example
of
how it can't
you know sometimes people will raise the
complaint of oh
this might make
it more
it might make it more difficult for
us to have enough energy for everyone
if uh we
shut off power plants like bow but
since we barely ever use it anyways i i
don't think it really
uh it really would cause
too much harm
to
make it operate even less
okay thank you
thank you just as an fyi for you
representative gallagher
station and a bow is generating 420
megawatts of power even as we speak
um anybody else have any questions for
representative gallagher
seeing none
well there's representative pementel go
ahead thank you mr chairman and thank
you for uh
your work on this bill i'm i'm just
wondering if
um
going after
rates
as the
place to be doing consideration as the
right place
having it be infrastructure or planning
to consider
climate change
um
so
i mean i don't think it's the only place
where there could also be
there could also be other places where
it's worth taking this into
consideration as well
but
this is just one one of the many places
where
i want to start
i want to start with
it's just what i thought of first
basically
any additional questions for
representative gallagher representative
mann
thank you mr chairman
um
the phrase after taking into
consideration their impact on climate
change are you asking
the commission to um
principles or decision criteria in terms
of what gets turned on and so on
are you are you suggesting that
the
since since
electric generators
charge a price for the electricity they
by essentially in
simplified way to buy electric power
from generators and
sell it to
that
a way that perhaps representative man
could you pull your microphone a little
closer we're having trouble hearing
i thought you're going to thank you to
stop
um
are you suggesting that it's up to say
the public utilities commission to
handle this with rates for example if um
a polluting plant was forced to charge a
well
then people wouldn't then the utilities
wouldn't buy power from that producer
for example
you're suggesting that all this
consideration on how to make this
actually happen is you're leaving it up
to the public utilities commission i
guess that's my question
um at least as this bill
currently stands i would like to get
those criteria figure out
of how um and to help them with this job
of how to figure it out
um
handled in
an amendment i believe
yeah somebody was actually sending to me
last night but i managed to get by ols
in time to
um
get that turned into amendment an
amendment yet um
so
um
but yeah if
yeah until until we pass that i guess
they they would be able to figure that
uh representative harrington has a
question
yeah thank you mr chairman thank you
taking my question i think
there's an awful lot of confusion here
so i'm trying to figure out exactly what
you understand about how rates get set
do you understand that
the puc sets electric rates on a lot of
things a good portion of which is the
contracts that the utility brings to
them and says this is how we're going to
provide our power to our customers over
the next six months usually there's
multiple contracts it's broken up into
you know maybe 50 50 or maybe 35 35
whatever
and
those contracts come in with a supplier
that the whether it be eversource or
unitel decides they're going to do based
on getting their someone who can meet
their load profile and then can also
give them the best price
and on a day-to-day basis that contract
is fulfilled by the supplier to the
utility based on what's available in the
market for electricity and for example
as chairman votes just mentioned okay i
just want to know if do you understand
what i'm talking about on how the rates
were set
um
i've i mean i i guess
or
thank you for that explanation i'm not
really sure how i'm supposed to reply to
it
um
that's quite all right um it's a
complicated subject
are there any additional questions for
seeing none and having no additional
uh representative california i have a
question for the chair yes the uh
representative gallagher
said he got an amendment would you
advise him on how he can get an
amendment if he went through
a member of the committee who could
introduce the amendment for him could
you explain that to him i'm sure he
doesn't understand the process
okay representative gallagher
now that you have introduced this bill
hb 1250 to our committee it no longer
belongs to you it's now our bill it
belongs to the committee
therefore any amendments that get made
to this bill will have to be initiated
by a member of this committee
now you can approach a member of the
committee and ask them to initiate an
amendment on your behalf
and if they agree
they will do so but it will be their
amendment
you could potentially be a co-sponsor on
the amendment but it would be the
committee member's amendment yeah and uh
now that we don't typically excuse me
let me finish we don't typically
consider amendments during public
hearings we consider amendments either
during a subcommittee work session or
during an executive session
so the time to submit an amendment would
be
on the occasion of one of those
other meetings
right now we have no plans to do a
subcommittee on this bill but that could
change
your first step
and i'm following through on
representative callie pitts's request
your first step would be to approach a
member of the committee to try to find
if find out if there's someone who would
be willing to submit an amendment on
your behalf
well um i believe i believe my
co-sponsor representative oxenham or i
don't see her here today but she's on
this committee isn't she
she is yes
yeah so
um yeah i'm i i know people on this
committee oh
i'll do that
representative mcwilliams for example
represents
the flow tarial that
i'm in so
okay i just wanted to follow through on
representative callie pitts's request
that you fully understand how the
process works
yeah okay
are there any
other
representative mcgee thank you um
i had thought quite a bit about this
when i was asked to represent it and um
i just wanted to say that earlier today
we had a discussion around the true cost
of a product being built in
and i think that that's a really
important point for us to think about in
the intent of this bill
it just struck me when i heard that
argument because
i think what's happening here is that
if we're not considering the
externalized costs
of how
climate change is something we're all
going to be paying for especially maybe
people of
representative gallagher's generation
i think that that's the intent of the
bill is to try and figure out some way
to have the
the true cost incorporated into forms of
generation that
that cost us more in the long run i
thank you for your comment uh
representative platt
yes thank you this is directed to
representative mcgee
how does the puc have anything to do
i don't think the public utilities
commission does have anything to do with
generation
but i think they oversee
how
generation is implemented in the market
and they have rate cases on various
types of generation and how they get
implemented and if they're not taking
climate into consideration in those
conversations then you may get a
different outcome in terms of
how the costs uh or benefits are
allocated
so we seem to be straying into
the realm of a discussion about this
bill as opposed to a public hearing
so uh
i would like to get a sense from the
committee would you like to
since we have a half hour roughly
left in before we have to tackle our
next bill would you like me to
uh reset not recess but end during this
public hearing and open a full committee
work session on this bill to have a
discussion
um just
for a heads up i have another bill that
i'm introducing at uh
at 2 15 so i wouldn't be able to stay
for the
whole time your presence wouldn't be
required at a full committee work
session anyway so
thanks
okay so all those who would like to have
a full committee work session on this
bill raise your hands please
one
five six
seven all those who
don't really want to have a full
committee work session
one
two three four five six seven
eight
so it looks like eight to seven with me
abstaining for now
uh
we're not going to have a full committee
work session nevertheless i'm going to
all right representative creation has a
question
thank you for your indulgence chair um
getting back to the question of
incorporating um
the sort of externalities can you speak
to why
setting it in the rates by the puc would
be better than other mechanisms that
we've talked about like carbon taxes or
other ways of incorporating those
externalities
um i mean if we can do one of those
other methods then create the um
but
i don't see
one of those other methods necessarily
happening anytime soon
so
um you know i i believe in
trying every method
that's possible
and um
and just doing do it doing what's what's
possible to do
so um
this is more yeah this is kind of just
like a backup in case some of the other
things you were discussing don't
okay thank you representative
so
we now do have another pink card so
thank you i'd like to thank
representative gallagher for his
testimony and representative mcgee for
being a stand-in
and i would like to call to the stand
or to the table
representative i mean
griffin roberge from the department of
energy
[Music]
good afternoon chairman vos members of
the committee uh for the record griffin
roberge from the new hampshire
department of energy here to
provide neutral testimony on house bill
um
while the department doesn't take any
position on this uh we did want to note
a number of uh
technical concerns
um much in line with what representative
harrington had mentioned um
on lines nine eight and nine after
taking into consideration their impact
on climate change
the bill does not specifically spell out
any criteria for the public utilities
commission to
consider climate change are we looking
at reduction of greenhouse gases are we
looking at
you know any number of issues
um so if this bill were to proceed we'd
like to see
you know we'd prefer that there'd be a
little bit more of clarification there
because the puc by and large is an
economic regulator helping set electric
rates and that type of thing
they're not an environmental regulator
so if this were to proceed as is
the department respectfully anticipates
that without any clear criteria there
would be a
very strong likelihood
that there would be additional staff
requirements for nearly every single
party and every single rate case so that
would mean department of energy we need
to hire a consultant who's well-versed
in climate change um the utilities the
puc as well
um
again without any clear criteria it
might it might slow down the process of
of of
puc rate cases
there is
some level but not you know abundant
consideration of climate change in
um lease cost plans that are reviewed by
the public utilities commission lease
cost energy planning is spelled out in
rsa
colon 37 and it requires every electric
and natural gas utility to submit one of
these plans and within those plans
there's and i'm just
mentioning out of the statute
um assessment of plan integration and
impact on state compliance with the
clean air act of 1990 and other
environmental laws
an assessment of the plan's long and
short-term environmental
economic energy price and supply impact
what else here there's a
assessment of supply energy options
including owned capacity market
procurements renewable energy and
distributed energy resources so
there are two active lease cost plans uh
being reviewed by the public utilities
commission currently unitel has one
under
20-002
and then liberty utilities has one under
de21-004
for reference for the committee
that basically concludes my testimony uh
certainly willing to take any questions
and i'll try to answer them as best as
possible
representative callie piss is recognized
for a question
my question was going to be do you
believe that the
public utilities commission can set
criteria
or that we can direct them to put in
certain criteria
even if they might have to
hire an extra employee or the department
of energy would sure again
it's just based on the language in eight
eight and nine there just isn't a clear
criteria as to what should be
considered for climate change i mean if
there was criteria put in i'm sure the
department and the puc would
would uh
would uh certainly appreciate it but at
this time it's it's just quite broad in
general
follow-up
i'm going to follow up because i i i
believe at this point you know
we've heard a lot of testimony from the
department of energy and
i'm not very happy with it but we talk
about aesthetics
we don't say what aesthetic that you
can't block a cloud or you can't block a
mountain or
so we do have
and that's for the puc that's for the
site evaluation we do have some broad
criteria that we do put in i'm not
speaking for or against this bill but
i'm saying that that if we wanted to do
this
we could do it and there are other
examples in statute that have broad
criteria
would you agree with that sure and you
know referencing as you said the site
evaluation committee um in reviewing
aesthetics you know the
site evaluation committee certainly
nailed down i think in rules you know
certain things such as the stacks for
wind facility projects and that type of
thing but again in turn in terms of this
you know at least having some additional
clarity i don't have the site evaluation
committee statute in front of me but um
you know having some additional clarity
in terms of climate change would be
okay representative plett is recognized
for questions thank you thank you for
taking my question you referred to the
statute directing
lease cost plans
uh
is that i mean the statute's still there
but is that somewhat archaic since the
industry has been deregulated so yes
class plans should only address
transmission and distribution and not
generation correct and again i wasn't
referencing it as you know the best
alternative but it does consider in some
respects not entirely you know some
climate change aspects in terms of
compliance with environmental laws and
thing did you need a follow-up no
representative samsung is recognized
thank you mr chairman thank you mr
roberts for taking my
question um
would you agree with me that all energy
sources have
a variety of external costs that they
might
create
sure i mean i'm sure that energy
resource and some
energy generation resources have
external costs but again it's not
anything
that
the puc actively considers i guess
because they're largely focused on
distribution and
distribution rates and that type of
thing so you know the puc as has been
mentioned don't get
heavily involved in generation review
and that type of thing and the release
of carbon emissions so that type of
thing
follow-up
thank you mr chairman
but
that is exactly my point so who does
consider those external costs and who
puts them into the rates yeah i mean
it's not something that's currently in
statute right now that'd be a decision
thank you
okay any additional questions for mr
roberge
uh representative harrington
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
as far as how they get into rates
um
would you agree that for example we've
talked about the bow power plant here
today they have a scrubber on it that
costs uh well over 400 million dollars
and there's other pollution control
devices on there so would you agree that
their cost is uh impacted greatly by the
pollution controls they have and that's
how those costs get put into rates
okay
any more questions for mr roberge
seeing none i thank you for your uh
testimony thank you very much
enlightening as always and with no
having been filed i will close the
public hearing on hb 1250 and remind
representative gallagher that you need
to submit a pink card
thank you
okay we'll be in recess until our next
public hearing on
representative
remember i will need a pink card
eventually
i will need a pink card from you
oh
um
uh
okay
okay it's 2 30 and time to resume our
activity here
so i would like to open the public
requiring notification to renewable
energy customer generators of issues
related to renewable energy credits
i'm going to introduce the prime sponsor
of this bill representative oxenam
and representative oxenham would like to
make a statement before she begins her
formal testimony on this bill
representative thank you mr chair thank
you colleagues for your attention
i have filed a conflict of interest with
the
office of legislative services on this
bill and i am now making a verbal
disclosure
that
this bill could affect
a property claim
i am a renewable energy owner customer
generator
having a cessation of wreck sweeping
would restore my rights to my property
it would stop the taking of the property
and that could be considered a financial
interest
so as a serving member of this committee
and in consideration of the bill before
us i am
verbally acknowledging that i have a
special interest
and i am doing so verbally it is also
possible that if we are unable
to rectify this issue legislatively that
there may be a legal action in which i
would be a party and there also i might
have a financial interest to disclose
thank you for making that statement can
i ask a quick question do you know if
you will have to recuse yourself from
executive session on this bill
i spoke with mr rich lambert on that
matter and it's a little unclear because
of this issue of the cessation of a
practice which is now
ongoing
constituting a financial interest so uh
i
could i simply say that it's under i'm
taking that under advisement looking
into it and i will make sure before the
executive session that that is resolved
thank you i appreciate that
so
please give us your testimony on this
bill thank you
um an amendment has been passed out
and i would just like to explain why
there is both a bill and an amendment
at the time of our lsr window i was
under the impression that we could not
file legislation that would be
substantively similar to something that
came up last year
but since this bill never made it to the
floor and no action was taken on it that
provision actually didn't apply
so the bill before you is is convoluted
and difficult
it's presented as a consumer
notification bill and so it has all that
legalistic language it's about as
interesting as reading a credit card
small print
but it
tries to accomplish the same thing as
the amendment the amendment is simply
very simple
very straightforward let's eliminate the
provision that creates the problem
so i will be speaking to
that goal
it's not specific either to the
amendment or to the bill since they both
try to accomplish the goal of stopping
an unconstitutional taking of property
so the fundamental purpose of hb 1645
is to put an end to an unconstitutional
taking of property by the state and the
transfer of that property to private
corporations
both new hampshire's public utilities
and also out-of-state multi-billion
dollar corporations like constellation
energy and direct energy
a practice that is going on without the
knowledge or consent of new hampshire
residents or businesses
and without any compensation for the
taking
first rec sweeping is a taking because
electricity providers are enabled to use
customer generators property for their
own purposes
and it is a taking because in so doing
it prevents the customer generator
from using their property in their own
interest
the property taken
is the renewable attributes of the
electricity that customer generators
produce
renewable attributes are the essence of
what makes renewable energy renewable
and to be clear they are created at the
very moment the electricity is generated
they can be separated from the physical
electricity
and like any kind of property they can
be bought sold or transferred
if you separate the renewable attributes
from the electricity produced by a
renewable source
it is no longer renewable energy
the ftc says it is now
null
electricity
so to be clear
renewable attributes are the property
interest that wrecks
represent and convey
and new hampshire statutes
state and federal case law
federal guidance
and multiple new england pucs make it
abundantly clear
that renewable attributes exist
regardless of whether they are ever
registered as wrecks
and may i just say as an aside sometimes
statutes refer to rex as renewable
energy certificates and sometimes they
refer to them as renewable energy
credits
new hampshire's rec sweeping section
masks
the underlying reality of this taking
by referring to it as crediting
but in practice rec sweeping strips the
renewable attributes from customer
generators electricity production
and transfers it to electricity
providers
both public utilities and private
corporations in basically a 50 50 split
and they use them
for their rps compliance requirements
so in doing this the state is taking the
property
they are transferring the right to use
it to private corporations
and all the renewable attributes which
we commonly but misleadingly often refer
to as rex
all the renewable attributes used for
rps compliance
legally become part of the electricity
that the providers supply
and rps anti-double counting provisions
prohibit anyone else from claiming that
they also use those same renewable
attributes
and claiming them as something they
produce and consume
federal law likewise prohibits customer
generators from claiming to use the
renewable energy they produce
if that renewable energy is being
counted toward a state rps mandate
again this is an anti-double counting
provision otherwise you would be
believing that you had double the
renewable energy being produced in the
state then you do
when it comes to any action affecting
commerce a business that claims to be a
hundred percent renewably powered
if they've sold their wrecks they are in
violation of the statute and can be
prosecuted i believe it's a ten thousand
dollar a day
fine for any business that would find
itself unknowingly in this situation
so what are the key property rights that
the consumer generator loses as the
result of this unconstitutional taking
of their property
first it renders null and void their
intention
in in investing in renewable energy if
they wanted to move off of fossil fuels
if they wanted to reduce their carbon
footprint if they just wanted to live
less destructively on the planet
that has been rendered null and void by
the taking
secondly
it subverts their desire to create more
renewable energy additional to the
minimum requirement mandated by the
state under the rps
final point
to add insult to injury
by producing this energy which they did
to meet their own needs
they reduce the total pool of energy
that is subject to rps compliance
and so that by by producing renewable
energy less money less electricity has
to be purchased so the total pool of
energy that's subject to compliance has
been reduced
and then they get to credit these
swept wrecks
against that already reduced requirement
so they've had two two dips at
actually subverting the original
legislative intent of having a renewable
portfolio standard
new hampshire state law especially
recognizes that increasing renewable
energy generation is in the public
interest
rsa 362 f colon 1 states quote
it is therefore in the public interest
to stimulate investment in low emission
renewable energy generation technologies
in new england and in particular in new
hampshire
the provision this bill seeks to remove
is a poison pill that was introduced
subsequently to the creation of the
statute
and it actively works against the
original legislative intent of the
statute
it is an unconstitutional taking of
residents and businesses property
by a stealth process accomplished out of
sight and without the knowledge of many
of those at harms
we can do the right thing
and remove this pernicious policy by
legislative action
or we can allow it to stand where it
will be subject to legal challenge
potentially costing the state and our
taxpayers in excess of 10 million
dollars in legal costs
i ask you to take the first choice
support the amendment
and let's remove this provision from
statute
thank you
thank you representative oxidom
all right do we have questions for
representative oxenom representative
platt yes uh thank you for your
statement do you have it in written form
you can submit
it it's a little scratched up i will
submit it electronically to you this
afternoon when i get home thank you
every time i read it i you know
representative harrington
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question just so i'm clear
what we're talking about here
these uh swept up wrecks are these the
wrecks that we changed the amount from i
think was last year where it was a 20
that considered a 20 capacity factor
down to a 13 and a half percent is that
the ones we're referring to it is and
that was a positive move in changing
that because the there was an
exaggerated
value attached to each of those wrecks
when they were falsely considered to be
producing at the rate of 20 percent
follow-up mr chairman follow up okay so
the people that are not registering
their wrecks and they're now we're
working under the assumption that
there's a thirteen and a half percent
capacity factor for whatever their size
of the solar array is
would most of these people have to
install uh fairly expensive uh measuring
equipment in order to comply with the
requirements so they could actually sell
you you caught me there at the very end
by going to sell their wrecks because
that's different than what i thought you
were going to go for which was to retain
their wreck so so let me
back up and and answer well let me
clarify i mean if they say retain with
the idea
if they're not going to do anything with
them at all then they wouldn't need the
measuring equipment but if they were
going to either sell them to the utility
or sell them on the market they would
need additional instrumentation is that
correct
there was again there was a recent
provision change that has made it easier
um
in in general anybody who's had their
system for a while is going to have to
create
to do exactly what you said and have an
auditor and a monitor and such things so
that you know first of all people don't
know what's happening that they need to
take those steps
um
and if they don't want to be engaged in
a sale
they wouldn't think that they needed to
so the the notion here under the
original bill was to to
have them informed that this is going on
and that there is the possibility of
registering and retaining um
but that's not included in the amended
bill
no the amended bill simply removes the
provision so you don't have to inform
people that they're being harmed thank
you
okay thank you
additional questions for
representative uh
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative oxnghem i just want to
kind of
recap if i understand correctly the
process here and
i just want you to confirm that that's
what's happening
that's basically my query here
so basically if i have an installed
solar array
and i'm not interested because i don't
want to get into the complications of
monitoring or
selling or all that stuff i don't want
to get into that i just like to generate
my own energy
and i have this collector and
so if i don't do anything to it in the
way of uh
marketing it somehow or monetizing it
somehow
uh currently
my utility can claim that energy for its
portion of its requirement
to generate some solar energy
they can say that's that's ours
and we're going to use that to credit it
against our obligations
and they don't have to notify me that
they're using my energy or they don't
have to compensate me in any way for it
is that correct is that the current
system
very close
compensate for using it it they've taken
it they're not just you know what
prop a property right what is inherent
in owning property is that you have the
right to dispose of it and you have an
exclusive right to dispose of it someone
else is granted the right to use it
you no longer have the right to use it
you cannot even claim that you are
producing and consuming it at home
and and a final thing which i think
was raised there
is the point that um
because the capacity factor is is being
put against the
um
it's not simple
i'm sorry i'm having something called
i think i think i can get it wait a
second
they are not only taking the excess
energy they are taking also
a value the property to what you
self-consumed because that the they are
applying this capacity factor to the
size of your array and an assumption
about the the days of sun if it's a
solar system so because the assumption
is based on your total production
you're not only losing the claim to what
is put back out onto the grid you are
losing also the property right in even
what you
have self-consumed behind the meter
yeah thank you
representative thomas is recognized for
a question thank you mr chair thank you
for taking my question i apologize for
coming in late during your presentation
so
i'll ask this question uh i know that
the bill as introduced is here and i'm
assuming you were speaking a little bit
about the amendment that you would like
to be introduced or you know taken over
in either case
if this was enacted
would this cost the ratepayer any more
money
both the bill
are
aimed at accomplishing the same thing
which is to stop this this process
um so that that was to settle your first
question
the second question was about the effect
on the rate payers
last year when we discussed this bill i
remember that it was mentioned
by someone
that
this saves the rate payers money
in fact the electricity providers
are not simply our public utilities they
are also
large
multi-billion dollar outside
corporations so that the property
interests
of new hampshire residents and
businesses are being transferred by the
state
to
out-of-state
private corporations and as i don't know
if you were here when i said it's about
50 50. i think it's 48 of the total pool
goes to the competitive suppliers and
about 52 rounded off
goes to the utilities so for the
utilities
they are required to pass on any savings
to their the ratepayers for the
competitive suppliers who you know have
absolutely no contact with the customer
generators and no interest in them or
our ratepayers
it's simply cream it's just excess
follow follow-up
um
since you mentioned it just for
clarification uh the bill that you
referred to last year was that hp 396
the one that was i tailed in this
committee last year is that the one you
were referring to
when you spoke about the bill that was
i was under the impression that that
bill was one of the ones that was not
considered on the floor when we had that
marathon session that ran late
but you may if if you are correct that
it was itled in committee
then
that
then we
i'm just trying to kill fight myself
that's all well we would we we will
definitely find out before we get to our
work session if if in fact that was what
happened
yes since i made the motion on the floor
i know for a fact that hb 396 was itled
by this committee but then it was tabled
on the floor
and the house rules say that a bill
that's been tabled
has not been
acted upon acted upon by the house
therefore it can be brought back again
the following year so that that is the
uh parliamentary situation with that
bill i think uh
representatives thomas question was
it is
it has the same goal
it is not literally the same bill no
it's um you know if you compare the two
texts they
you know they are different
okay thank you after a year of legal
research and talking with lawyers from
around the country on this issue it's a
better bill
than the one we had last year
okay thank you representative callie
i'm trying to get things straight in my
own mind
most of the energy and correct me if i'm
wrongly most of the energy
that we are talking about has already
been
net metered
to the company
and the company has indeed bought it by
paying
a credit back to the customer is that
correct uh no one in fact there's a
provision that says that that the two um
the one cannot be
credited the other there are people who
have their wrecks swept who are net
metered
who
receive no rebate
there are people who did receive rebates
who are not swept
it it's the the two the two are not um
they overlap but they're not um you know
convergent sets you know they're not
they're not the same thing
what is the difference
between
sweeping wrecks
and aggregating reps
rex
aggregating rex are you thinking about
community power aggregation
i'm thinking about
may i clap
yes go ahead i'm thinking about a
discussion we had several years ago in
this committee about
letting the
utilities ag
in essence what you call sweeping put
the wrecks together because there were
many people who didn't want to bother
with
the paperwork etc and we called that
aggregation i believe i may be very
confused but that's what i seem to
remember
if you can't answer it it might have
been well no it wouldn't have been that
because i've been here since 2014 and
this came in in 2012 unless it was in
the 2012-2013 session i don't recall the
discussion of aggregation in in terms of
wrecks
um
but but i think you had
you had two points there that was only
go ahead no that that that was that we
had the two points who answered the
first one and maybe there's somebody
else uh from a utility who can answer my
question i think it okay that's a good
point but i think it's also that it's
not simply your utility
that gets the wreck that's swept it's a
pool so
all of them are gathered together with
this um
i'm going to use the word fictitious
which is not the right word uh you know
this
nobody knows how much is being produced
so you take the capacity factor times
the actual size of the arrays and then
some notion about how much sun there was
and you create this number and then you
divide it up
between everybody so it your your swept
wreck may go to
the out of state multinational in north
carolina or your swept wreck may go to
your actual local utility but you would
have no way of knowing and they would
okay i can provide some clarification
here
a customer generator sells a wreck
a utility buys a wreck
but the utility doesn't buy it directly
from the customer generator there's
always a middleman
and these middlemen
brokers of wrecks frequently are called
aggregators
they collect together a bunch of wrecks
and then go to you to eversource or you
unitil and say i've got 10 000 recs that
i can sell you
and i'll sell them to you for this price
that's
what
may i clarify with the chair
go ahead
did
did we
[Music]
and i i seem to remember this did we as
a committee authorize that
i don't remember the committee
specifically authorizing it it is
authorized in statute and in commission
rules
it
i i don't remember when that happened
exactly maybe when the rps was initially
passed back in 2007 2008 that was before
i was in the legislature you may
remember but i don't
um
but that is the way it works
if i made that's with reference to the
sale of rex and that's not the issue
here swept wrecks were never offered for
sale
correct
uh representative mcgee is recognized
thank you mr chairman um my question
takes us back to the part of your
testimony where you mentioned
having looked into the legal research
over the last year making this a better
bill
you mentioned that you thought that
there could be a lawsuit against the
state
for for
basically undertaking a practice that
uh results in property taking i guess is
the easiest way to say it
so if that's the case
um
how do we
protect against that i guess and should
we protect against that because it
sounds like what you're saying is we
have a liability here
uh that maybe these people have no idea
they could have a class action suit or
whatever but that we have some kind of a
liability that we need to
insulate the state from does that make
sense
i'm not a lawyer
but i've listened to a lot of lawyers
and i've consulted with a lot of lawyers
and it's my understanding
that if the legislature were to remove
this provision
there would not be
the
animating um
motivation to go to a class-action
lawsuit to reclaim past damages
when the plaintiff's concern is
primarily to end the practice because
the practice itself unconstitutional
and is an imposition which which is
harming the members of members of the
state
taking their property without their
knowledge and without compensation
um that that would be if the legislature
were to take that action and and cease
and desist
with with its activity it it would
render it very unlikely that that legal
to follow up on
representative mcgee's question can you
cite
the supreme court case that makes wreck
i have
a um
the supreme court case that makes it
unconstitutional what makes it
unconstitutional
from a due process angle
is that property is being taken by the
state without notice and without
compensation not for a public purpose
you don't need a supreme court decision
for that that's what the constitution
says
um there has been no legal action much
less rising to the supreme court which
would have them weigh in on whether in
fact there is a due process claim
um so there's a procedural side to the
constitutional issue and there's also a
substantive side
which is that
property is being seized
and the the the owner of the property
has no recourse
so as a follow-up i think i said that
right the
constitutional
unconstitutional deprivation that your
bill specifically mentions is a presumed
or potential
unconstitutionally
unconstitutional deprivation
but it hasn't been that it has not been
submitted to a court okay great thank
you
all right further questions for
seeing none i would like to thank you
oh sorry representative brezny you guys
got to raise your hands when i first
look at you
thank you for tuning in after i look
away he was thinking
yes
my question is does this bill only apply
to somebody who explicitly does not want
someone who wants to
sell their credits and enter into a
market relationship
would have to register them yes so that
they could be tracked by kneepool
yes
i guess it's more if somebody
wants to sell their credits then
would this help them in any way to sell
their credits
this does not change anything whatsoever
about the sale of rex
it doesn't does not touch that issue
does it make it easier
or help
okay uh any further representative
thank you chairman um
so
with respect to any lawsuit
why would not the court consider
unregistered wrecks
abandoned
property property um
okay i'll
maybe this will answer this is a federal
trade commission
provision
uh which to try to simplify it for for
folks a toy manufacturer places solar
panels on the roof of its plant to
generate power and advertises that its
plant is 100 solar powered the
manufacturer however sells rex based on
the renewable attributes of all the
power it generates
even if the manufacturer uses the
electricity generated by those solar
panels it has by selling wrecks
transferred the right to characterize
that electricity as renewable the
claim is therefore deceptive
and they are subject to litigation
for for fraud basically
so i i i it's kind of a
sideways answer to your question could
yes so abandoned property that was your
point why why would
unregistered wrecks not be considered
abandoned property by any court
adjudicating this issue okay i think the
confusion is the term wreck which makes
people think that there's some
certificate thing that creates the
property
no it's clear from federal state law and
case law that the renewable attributes
which is what we should be talking about
the sweeping of renewable attributes
which are represented in rex
so the renewable attributes are created
the moment you create the energy they
are as it were bundled with the electron
if you try to separate them
you get a wreck that then represents
that renewable attribute and your
self-generated electricity that goes out
is now null it's not abandoned it's not
lost but it's characterized as null
electricity you can't call it renewable
the renewable attribute of the energy
has been transferred
to the new owner who is either the
purchaser of a wreck
or the
do you need a follow-up
no no follow-up no okay
uh representative samsuch
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative
uh
just to kind of clarify it seems to me
the question that was just asked about
abandoned property is a good one
but if i have a home
and it's registered in my town
and
i'm doing everything to maintain by law
uh if somebody tries to do something
with it they would have to notify me
about it before anything can happen
so
uh
if you have something that you own and
then your poc knows that you own this
solar
array
and somebody wants to do something with
it
yeah if you're not around you don't
react to any kind of notification or
information i guess people could say you
abandoned it but in this case people
aren't abandoning it that's still theirs
they just don't know any someone's doing
something with their property
i mean there is no notification there
there is no notice
that the property has been transferred
it hasn't been abandoned it was it was
originally owned by the generator
and then if it is conveyed to someone
else either by sale or sweeping
it's now owned by the other guy
okay thank you representative white is
recognized for a question
is it safe to say that this that these
are essentially
intellectual property and not tangible
physical property that is the uh i
yes
okay that's an appropriate
characteristic that's where a lot of
people get infused it is and and and
intangible property is a more difficult
concept yeah just want to clarify that
thank you
representative thomas is recognized for
a question
thank you miss chair and this strictly
just for clarification in my own mind
please um
so
are you implied and intellectual
property was a good one to come up
but
i seem to hear the fact that this all
pertains to what people
know they have and are
using it but someone might be taking it
away from them so my question is
is this the case where people are
generating
more power than they're using and they
they would have rex if they were
registered but they're not but they have
this excess power that they don't even
know they have
and they're not doing anything with it
so
is it in fact
uh taking of of intellectual property so
to speak that they don't know they have
i'm not sure if i if i'm asking the
right question but if you don't know you
ha you own something
and you're not planning to do anything
with something you don't know your own
how how is that taking away from you and
if if that makes any sense i'm just
trying to get a sense for for
people that don't have their power
directs registered
what are they losing and would they have
done something with them even though
they don't know they have it
you're getting to the very nub of the
issue and i thank you for the question
it's useful clarification
consumers
have
two uses for their property
in this particular arena
the one is that i can claim i'm doing my
best here to reduce my carbon footprint
i have invested in a solar array and i
am using that energy and i am putting it
out onto the grid for the benefit of
others
that's my primary use that's my primary
motivation in getting that array
my secondary use is i want to make sure
that we have fuel diversity in new
hampshire i want to make sure that
there's more renewable energy beyond
legally mandated minimums so i'm going
to do this i'm going to buy this array
i'm going to produce this energy to make
sure there is more renewable energy
available
okay
rex sweeping denies you both of those
first of all you cannot say you produce
and consume renewable energy because the
renewable attributes have been taken
away by state action and they have been
granted to corporations for their own
use
in the second case
which was creating more renewable energy
than the legally mandated minimum
by
by creating the array by using the
energy from the array i have diminished
the total amount of electricity that's
available
for the rps requirement so i've i've
reduced the corporation's
need to buy wrecks because i've reduced
the pool of electricity
and then you let them take
the wreck
and apply it
so there's it's not like a double
dipping but it's a double whammy
you you let them apply it to their
compliance so you further reduce the
legally required amount of renewable
energy that will be produced in new
hampshire
in fact if you if you run the numbers
and i had to do this many times because
it didn't make sense to me until i saw
it with the mathematical formula
you would have been better off not to
have invested in renewable energy there
would have been more renewable energy in
new hampshire
if you had not created and generated
that array
because of what you've done to the rps
compliance mechanism
less
is generated
follow-up
thank you mr chair thank you for the
follow-up so on point number one
am i correct that you're saying that uh
you you would be taking away the right
for someone to claim that they are
generating renewable energy
that is a property right yes right and
but point number two escapes me
uh in that
if they're not doing anything with the
excess power that they're generating
even if they even knew they had it
losing that into the grid because they
don't even know they have it and if
they're not using it how how are we
losing it
you're confusing the physical electron
which could be
lost into the grid with the property
right which is completely separated from
the physical electron you know when you
create it they're bundled together the
renewable attribute and the electricity
but as soon as there is a
taking of it by sweeping or a sale of it
you have split those two apart
and now the ability to say i use you can
have a coal-fired power plant produce
all of your energy for your factory but
if you buy rex you can say a hundred
percent green a hundred percent
renewable energy was used to produce
this product
because the renewable attributes were
conveyed by the transfer the property
right to claim
renewable
goes with the
with us with the wreck whether it's
swept or sold
thank you
representative cretian is recognized
thank you chair thanks for taking my
question so my understanding is it's
also taking away the person's ability to
sell their wreck if they wanted to
once it gets swept
they not only cannot say i've produced
renewable energy but if if i wanted to
sell those wrecks to an aggregator i
wouldn't be able to now it's a very
interesting question and i think you
might want to go to the sustainable
energy division which used to be at the
puc and is now over at doe and ask them
has
have i had my wreck swept it
am i entitled to register my production
and claim
my wrecks or has that already been taken
away from me and i have to wait until
next year or whatever the period is in
order to say hey
i'm going to register it i'm going to
retain it nobody's taking my property
away from me without my knowledge and
consent
much less compensation which is also
required by state takings
uh representative plett is recognized
thank you thank you for taking my
question
i don't want to attribute motive to any
person who's got
a a wreckable system uh but but some may
not care
it's too small they don't want a hassle
of paperwork how is that a taking then
if they're just not bothering and if if
if you've changed the law the way you
want doesn't that force
uh
essentially credit for something they
didn't want to follow through with it a
lot of other people are following
through
i i i don't
want to be fanciful but if i lived in
colorado and i owned 150 acres of uh
prairie land and i never saw it and
somebody else grazed their animals on it
am i harmed
by somebody else taking my property and
you can answer the question
i'm harmed
it's my property and somebody else is
taking it and using it and they're you
know creating erosion and they're doing
other things that you know maybe the
purpose that i bought the land for was
to make sure that prairie dogs could
flourish
okay we have two people uh two
additional people signed up to testify
on this bill
and as a result i'd like to move on if
that's okay with the other members of
the committee
so representative oxendine we really
appreciate you coming in and testifying
on this bill today and
please have a safe trip home
and
we will now call on griffin roberge from
the department of energy to testify on
i should have turned it off before i did
that yeah that would have worked
excuse me i have a question for the
chair
yes
it's a little bit a piece of me that's
feeling uncomfortable
if we've been told that we're going to
possibly have litigation
and these tapes of this meeting can be
discussing this at all
i i
i don't know but i feel uncomfortable
with that
well we're not discussing it we're
asking questions and getting answers and
that's the legitimate purpose okay of
our committee right
well i
but i have never come into a committee
meeting in 25 years where somebody has
said
if you don't do this this is probably
going to go to court knowing that these
tapes
and anything that's said in here
can be used and we can be witnesses so i
just wanted to know if there's a
clarification on that thank you
yes you're welcome
uh
i have heard of that kind of thing
happening in committee meetings on
numerous occasions so
maybe it's a first for this committee
but it's not a first for committees so
mr robarge you're uh on for uh your
testimony on this bill thank you thank
you mr chairman members of the committee
uh
griffin roberts from the new hampshire
department of energy here to
provide testimony in house bill 1645.
the department is neutral but however i
understand that there has been an
amendment introduced by representative
oxenham
i don't feel comfortable commenting on
it
until i
am able to look at it more thoroughly on
short glance it looks like it repeals
the uh class one and class two uh wreck
sweeping credit
um
that's currently in statute
initially i had intended to come here
today to testify on the substance of the
bill as introduced
the department
was unsure as to how it would
comply with what's on page three lines
one to seven it does in terms of this
notice that would be sent to customer
generators it would require the
department of energy to fulfill that
obligation i just wanted to note that
the department
you know isn't in the business of
conducting mass mailings to
customer generators or anything like
that and the language does allow the
department to
shift that responsibility to
distribution companies and
installers of renewable energy systems
that are eligible for net metering
given that that's a likelihood that
would take place if this bill were to
pass as introduced
cause some rate impacts at least for
the utilities and recovering the cost
for that mailing
additionally in the notice as well
the department had concerned with what
was said on page two line 18 to 28 where
regulatory action from the federal trade
commission there isn't any specificity
there in statute citing the
federal
rule or ftc rule that
for this regulatory action um certainly
we'll try to answer any questions that
people might have regarding the
uh
rps and the credit mechanism as i think
the committee has discussed that bill
that credit was amended last year with
representative harrington's house bill
reduced the capacity factor for that
credit from 20 percent to one that's
tied to iso new england it's around a
more
it is in statute currently and
everything like that is being used um i
can cite what the credit has been in
past compliance years but i couldn't
cite that for
anything recent just because that
information isn't readily available
so we'll only answer any questions that
the committee might have
but i realized that there was also some
discussion about
legal concerns i'm not a lawyer and i'm
not going to try to answer any questions
on that so
feel free to ask but you know i don't
think i can answer anything like that
definitively
okay thank you for your testimony
all right miss uh representative
pimentel
thank you mr chairman thank you uh mr
roberts
so
basically all of your comments were on a
bill that wasn't introduced and my
question is
uh the bill that was introduced simply
eliminates wreck sweeping could you
comment on how
that will affect anything yes so so the
amendment would repeal the credit you
know i can i can really only reference
to what was done what was mentioned in
the past um
give a little bit of context the puc
when the puc managed the renewable
portfolio standard
regularly conducted reviews every so
often on the on the art on the renewable
portfolio standard offer it was a
stakeholder driven process with a lot of
collaboration and
made recommendations to the legislature
as to what should change
there was some discussion in the last
review in 2018
on the class two net metering credit and
i can certainly provide that review with
members of the committee but in short
amongst the stakeholders who were
involved quote there was no consensus
amongst the stakeholders on the
necessity of the net metering credit for
class two
some stakeholders argued in favor of
retaining the credit because it reduces
the overall cost of compliance for
electric providers thereby reducing the
impact of rps compliance costs on
ratepayers
others thought the credit should be
eliminated to increase the market for
class two wrecks or reducedness of all
eligible solar pv sites in new hampshire
including those that are not rec
certified
additionally
because pv facilities for which the
credit is being claimed likely received
support from the renewable energy fund
i'll put attack on this for now the
renewable energy fund is funded through
alternative compliance payments under
the renewable portfolio standard to
provide
rebates to residents commercial
industrial customers to develop
projects that might produce wrecks to
help you know provide more wrecks to the
market
further because pv facilities for which
the credit is being claimed likely
received
support from the renewable energy fund
the energy generated from non-rec
certified net metered solar electric
facilities should contribute to the
state's renewable energy policy goal of
20 of uh renewed state's renewable
energy goal so i'm sorry representative
to answer your question
under the renewable portfolio standard
there are some entity or residents
businesses that received rebates to
create pv facilities and that was funded
through alternative compliance payments
the credit mechanism is a way to capture
those people who might not be rec
certified but did receive a renew a
rebate from the renewable energy fund
without that credit based on the review
there's isn't a real way to capture
those folks to help contribute to the
rps goals
hope that answers the question a little
bit mr chair a question for the chair
yes yes uh
just for clarification i i believe i
heard the representative's question
refer to the the amendment as being
introduced into the committee in fact it
cannot be
the bill as introduced is what's been
introduced to the committee and the
amendment uh can be spoken
to from from the originator uh but for
the record it was has not been
introduced in into the committee
yet
technically you are correct yes
okay apologies for that um
any further questions for mr roberge
seeing none i thank you whoops
representative harrington
uh thank you mr chairman uh mr rohlberg
it seems like you were reading from a
puc decision or what was that you just
yes i'm sorry this is the 2018 rps
review
um and again i can certainly share that
with members of the committee if people
want to go looking for it for themselves
it specifically starts on page 27
okay well let's move on then thank you
mr roberge for your testimony thank you
and
i will now call on
um
donna gamache who wants to testify on
thank you donna gamache with eversource
again this afternoon i appreciate your
indulging me i didn't intend to testify
this afternoon and i put the pink card
in before griffin had a chance to finish
and i think he really spoke to
everything that i wanted to say
but in a nutshell i'm waiting for
information back from our team
to show what does that look like when we
it's a it's a term of use whether you
call it sweeping or aggregating we call
it aggregating all of that power that um
wrecks are not being created by the
powers because it's too small
and so a decision had been made by you
the legislature that it since customers
are required to pay
um for the utilities to purchase the
wrecks to comply with the rps payment
that there in fact is renewable energy
being created that
they contributed to a fund to help
provide a grant to install those that it
would be applied against the requirement
from the utilities i know that the
sponsor did say
that
utilities
you know put that savings back to
customers we do not keep it but i wanted
to make sure that you understood that we
do not keep that um and oh i might have
it here now let me just see
so
um
last year it i was waiting for this to
come back is again i wasn't expecting to
testify
last year for our customers the savings
was a million
on their compliance for the rps
statewide it was roughly two and a half
million
so if you as a legislature determined
that you want to do it differently we do
not
we do not take a position on that that
is clearly in within your um rights to
do so i just wanted to clarify but i
think griffin did a good job that um we
why you why you made the decision to do
it in the first place that we don't keep
the dollars the dollars go back um to
our customers and with that i'm done
thank you
representative plett is recognized for a
question
to simplify what you just said if we
eliminate if we pass this bill it raises
customer rates by one million in your
case and two and a half million
statewide
um
that's
that's correct but it is in your um
purview i i would just say that i what i
heard the speaker say that excuse me the
sponsors say was that there's like a
social benefits to holding on to those
wrecks and not so that that utilities
continue to have to go out and purchase
more wrecks for that same amount of
power that it's in the it's in the best
interest of the public i leave that to
you to decide
thank you
uh representative samsich is recognized
thank you mr chairman thank you
miss kimash
i understand that one person's savings
is another person's expense
so if we're now
taking
this attribution
from some
of our residents
are we not using that to subsidize the
power from the utilities for other
residents but nonetheless we are taking
it for someone
without their permission without
compensation and yes of course it's
gonna have a beneficial impact on those
we're not taking them from
but the point of the sponsor i think was
that we shouldn't be doing this without
permission or or uh i mean so
don't you agree that when you're saying
okay this would cause an increase in the
in the uh
the cost of power to ratepayers
that's certainly true but we're doing it
at the cost of taking that attribution
i i think the best way to answer that is
that that's a determination that you
have to make
um we we're we're not in the business of
making that determination we're doing as
we're told based on what you as a
legislature determine as our goals i
understand thank you thank you
okay thank you uh representative
creation you have a question
thank you chair thank you for taking my
question um so you mentioned that some
people don't get their system certified
to create wrecks because it's just too
small is there actually a hard limit on
how much
energy you need to generate in order to
to to produce a wreck there is
and i think it's a one megawatt hour
right i thought so one megawatt hour and
we're talking about systems that are too
small for that
so um you know the original goal of the
renewable energy fund was for that to as
much as possible be empty because you
were giving the grants out as much as
you could get when you got them in you
gave them out and the grants are going
to create more and more and more
renewable energy so that you're actually
uh
getting to your goals so this was the
legislature's attempt to say okay if
you're if rate payers are putting money
into this fund then they should be
getting a little bit of all ratepay
should be getting a credit for that but
again
you heard the sponsor of this bill say
that there are other attributes that
that matter as well so i leave all that
representative callie pitts
i am totally confused
um
wrecks and rebates
if you and i know intellectual property
intellect isn't my thing
if you give
buy something from someone which you in
essence are doing when you give them
back credit for that power you are
paying them back
would you have to
deduct
the percentage of the power that
the
who paid was paid for
from the wreck
what's
available for rex
and that's just the way my convoluted
mind works
i i'm very sorry to admit that i'm not
quite sure i know what the question is
if if i
you have power i produce a mega water
power
you are going to rebate me through neck
metering
are you gonna deduct the 20
from what's eligible for a wreck
no no but should you that's just good
question that's a good question that i
that's it
thank you
okay thank you uh ms gamache
seeing no other questions for miss
kamash you can't answer ask questions
i'm sorry representative oxenam since we
have no other questions for mrs gamache
i will now call
kelly buchanan from clean energy new
hampshire
and before you uh
start speaking miss mccann ms buchanan
i'm going to open the public hearing on
and then i'm going to recess that public
hearing so that we can complete this
public hearing
so now please
state your testimony perfect thank you
so much mr chair and members of the
committee i promise to be brief seeing
as we're on a time crunch
and i've already submitted written
testimony to you today
i am here before you and for the record
my name is kelly buchanan i'm director
of legislative and regulatory affairs
for clean energy new hampshire and we
are in support of house bill 1645.
i know today that we've spoken about uh
briefly the the original intent of the
bill and the amendment um that's been
described regarding elimination of rex
sweeping um clean energy in new
hampshire is supportive of either option
on the table
i'm going to take a very brief step back
and have a little bit of more of an
elementary discussion of the renewable
portfolio standard and it really is new
hampshire's only policy to promote
renewable energy in the state and we see
that as important because it can help
grow our clean tech economy create
high-paying jobs and promote our energy
independence and so
under the rps the utilities as we've
heard are required to procure
these renewable energy credits from four
separate classes of renewable energy and
that creates a wreck market and so we
need two things for a healthy rec market
and that's a strong annual percentage
goal for each of those four classes and
then also that elimination of rec
sweeping which we see is problematic
so that occurs is what has been
previously discussed is when the
utilities
get those credits for free um and
use them
against their compliance for the rps and
so
there are a couple of diverse reasons
for why not all customer generators
register to sell their wrecks some
simply aren't aware of it it's usually
up to the installer to notify people of
what they're able to do
others you know it's just one more thing
that they have to do in terms of getting
that special meter and registering and
all of that paying an aggregator
in the case of smaller projects so
that's all concerning to us but we're
also concerned because in terms of wreck
sweeping when a utility is able to
secure those racks without having to pay
for their cost that does distort the
market for especially class 2 we've seen
in the past and this causes a market
distortion where prices can collapse
so we find that house bill 1645 is
necessary to ensure that we close the
rec sweeping loophole and ensure
customers are able to be more aware of
the opportunities available to them to
secure those racks and to be able to
sell them on the market so i would be
glad to take any questions although i
know we've discussed the topic at length
today already
okay thank you any questions for ms
buchanan
representative mcgee
thank you mr chairman um thank you mr
buchanan for your testimony
the question i have is you mentioned
about uh class two wrecks collapsing
that that the the market so i think that
that's something that a lot of folks on
the committee might benefit from more
information about so can you say
something about the value of the wrecks
in new hampshire and how you see that
being affected by this bill
sure so it's it's i likened it to basic
economics essentially when there's
there's a product in the market that the
the purchaser is getting for free
they're just incentivized to pay for
them at the cost and so the price
overall decreases
if you know
they've gone as low as five dollars per
megawatt hour for class two for example
um so that's concerning to us and we
want to make sure that the wreck market
and the intention of the rps to promote
renewable energy development is um
secured through this elimination of rec
sweeping
follow up thank you
um so you mentioned as low as five i'm
afraid i'm not sure of what you know a
healthy wreck market for
a class two license would be so could
you say anything about
you know if that's low how low is that
or what what what would be
uh desirable in the state of new
hampshire because we don't know that's a
good question and frankly i need to go
back and find out for you but i'd be
happy to follow up with the committee
thanks
all right thank you seeing no further
i'd like to move on otherwise we're
all right representative samsit i'll
thank you mr chairman uh i believe that
the prices are different in new england
states
when i sell my solar wrecks into the
connecticut market i get like 30 dollars
good point representative that is
correct
we are competing with other states that
more okay thank you ms mccann and that
wasn't a question so
all right um
seeing no further questions we thank you
miss buchanan for your testimony thank
you and i would like to now close the
public hearing on hb
and
resume the public hearing on hb 1258
and i would like to call on the prime
sponsor of hb 1258 representative
good afternoon
um
let me get back up a little bit on this
what this bill is supposed to do is to
help the implementation of the new
department of energy i think as many
people realize
uh during the budget bill last year in
hb2 there was a reorg which drastically
affected the puc and created a new
department of energy and affected other
departments as well
and as that was
went through kind of fast and there
wasn't a lot of public input into it
and it's a in fact is it was the best
attempt but
the people of the department of energy
have learned that some of the things
that were done need to be corrected
changed whatever to make the system make
the whole department more workable as
you would expect when a brand new
department has
been formed and it's also trying to
coordinate with the existing department
the puc
that some of this is going to be learned
as you go
so this bill was our first attempt
having met with the people from the puc
in the department of energy and you'll
see there's numerous changes in here
but we've also had subsequent meetings
from that
and we've decided it's been decided that
would probably make some additional
changes to a few things there's been
some conflicts contradictions found that
uh need to be corrected
so i'm not presenting amendment today or
bringing anything up as specific as that
other than behind me people will speak
from the department of energy they'll be
able to go over the specific uh answers
to questions and sort of give you the
philosophy of where we're heading my
recommendation to the chair is that we
have a subcommittee on this so that we
can have more input to come up with a
formal amendment that could then be
brought forward to the entire committee
so rather than waste any more time
flapping my gums here i'll unless
there's questions i'd uh defer to the
people from the department of energy
okay before we accept questions for
representative harrington
i would like to ask everybody
sitting in this room all the members
sitting in this room to consider whether
or not they would like to serve on a
subcommittee
on this bill
at the end of this public hearing i'm
going to be asking for volunteers to
staff that committee which will be
chaired by representative harrington
so
representative kelly pitts you have a
question it's a question for the chair
subcommittees will be open to all
members they won't be members of the
committee but they'll be open
is that correct that is correct there
will be five members of the subcommittee
who will vote on a recommendation
and that will be the motion on the floor
when we go to exec session but anybody
can attend a subcommittee meeting
thank you
all right so
do we have questions for representative
harrington i would suggest that maybe we
might want to wait and question members
of the department of energy but
representative mcgee if you want go
ahead thank you mr chairman uh maybe you
can answer this for me representative
i'm just looking at the
bolded language on page one that talks
about the division conducting an audit
related to the operation of the public
utilities in the state and i was just
wondering
who
among the enforcement agencies in the
doe would have the ability or the
capabilities
to do perform an audit of the public
utilities because that seems like
it seems like an out of scope thing to
me i i just i'm not sure what it's there
for i will have to defer some of this to
the specific people in the department of
energy because it is a kind of a fluid
system my understanding that at least
some of the auditing folks that used to
work for the puc now work for the doe
some of that responsibility has been
transferred and hopefully some of the
expertise that went along with them
because i know from experience they had
a very good auditing department there
okay thank you you're welcome
so for the information of the members of
the committee we do have
chris elms from the department of energy
who signed up to testify and eric wind
from the puc who has signed up to
testify so we'll be hearing from both of
those folks in just a moment
unless there are further questions for
representative harrington
seeing none i would invite uh
assistant uh commissioner of the
department of energy chris elms to
give us his testimony on this bill thank
you
and i will apologize uh i'm joined by
david shulock general counsel for the
department of energy yeah so for the
record my name is chris elms i am the
deputy commissioner of the new hampshire
department of energy uh thank you very
much um for allowing us to testify today
mr chairman members of the committee
uh david is passing
along some
potential
further amendments
but as representative harrington
mentioned
the restructuring of the new hampshire
of the public utilities commission and
the creation of the new hampshire
department of energy uh in hb2 was a
very significant undertaking
uh even during those initial
conversations and and that included you
know with members of this committee i
everyone
agreed that there would likely be the
need for additional technical changes
after the restructuring restructuring uh
settled in and we you know could sort of
take the time to look at the effects and
come back with some suggestions so house
bill 1258 is the vehicle for those
items uh they are for the most part
housekeeping items technical changes and
clarifications that we think the
legislature ought to consider
um we've had a number of conversations
with uh the bill sponsor representative
harrington uh as well as the puc and
other stakeholders about um their input
on that uh these suggestions are are
mainly those of the department and i'm
sure you'll hear from others
the bill before you
included a number of changes and
you know given legislative deadlines to
get those in uh those requests for
changes have continued to evolve over
the succeeding months um you know given
the uh
willingness of the committee to do a sub
committee uh and and take um time to
work on it the department would be more
than happy to participate to whatever
extent
this committee uh desires
um so i'm gonna let david touch on some
of the high points of both
the underlying hp 1258 as well as some
additional potential
good afternoon the chair may i ask the
spelling of your last name david
it is s h u
okay
so uh good afternoon my name is david
shulock i'm the general counsel at the
department of energy see if you can get
as close to the mic as possible thank
you
[Music]
my name is david shulock i'm the general
counsel at the department of energy and
i would like to thank the sponsors of
this bill
for bringing it forward it was quite a
project
during the budget session to
reorganize the puc and create the
department
and there are some loose ends
from that process and they were good
enough to
bring a general bill forward
that we could work on during this
session with
stakeholders
that want to participate to clean up
those loose ends right so
i think just about everything that is
suggested uh in in the bill
and in the the further amendments that
the department would suggest
are generally of a housekeeping nature
or
you might look at
at it as
in that reorganization
people move to the department but the
language and the statute didn't match or
the language and the statute
changed but the people
didn't follow
right
but
we believe we understand the general
intent of
that reorganization and these changes
are designed to bring everything in line
right
and i will warn you that i've been
through this a number of times before
and going through each provision of
the bill as proposed and the
nine or ten changes that we're proposing
takes about an hour and a half to two
and a half hours depending
depending on the the questions so
i propose that i just point out to you
some of the high points leave this
document with you and then that we work
with the study commission to put flesh
on the bones
of all of these suggestions rather than
trying to go through it today if you
want to do that i'm more than happy to
and to answer any questions that you
have
but to start out uh some of the
important changes that we we would
really like to see made
are
if you look at
sections
9 and 10
of the
bill is introduced
these transfer authority
over
utility
disconnects and terminations of service
and medical disconnections
uh all of the
sort of consumer protection apparatus
uh and and much of the consumer
protection responsibility was
transferred to the department
under house bill 2
all of the people who conduct that work
were transferred over to the department
at that time
not transferring
the responsibility under this statute
was simply an oversight
right so it has the public utilities
commission doing things that it doesn't
have the rules infrastructure for doing
or the staffing to do all of that moved
over to the department so even though
it's a full statute that really is
in our view a housekeeping matter to
have the
statute follow where the the
we have asked for housekeeping in the
field of utility assessment
so the general responsibility for
assessing the utilities for the costs of
moved to the department
but there are numerous stray references
in the statute to the commission
leaving everybody wondering well who
exactly am i supposed to submit this
report to or who exactly is going to
contact me about that is it going to be
the commission or the department so we'd
like to make
we would like to see
the state's crossing statute changed so
before a utility or a utility type
company
can
cross
a state park or a piece of state land or
a public water
they had to receive a license to do that
from the public utilities commission and
that was handled
in an adjudicative procedure before the
public utilities commission
that responsibility was split
by house bill 2
right
leaving
the department to grant most licenses
but when there was disagreement among
parties then the public utilities
commission would do that
but in that process they
retained the adjudicative nature
of that process through its entirety
leaving the department
to conduct adjudications at least to
determine who the parties were
and under our proposal
we would like to see
that
licensing be completely
um administrative
right without an adjudicative proceeding
to get to the license itself
and then if a hearing is necessary if
somebody disagrees
uh with a decision that the department
there would be an appeal right
to the public utilities commission to
actually have that adjudicative
proceeding if one is necessary
in my experience at the puc
uh those adjudications were hardly
ever necessary right um most
even even some of the most controversial
crossings that you can think of
there was no disagreement whatsoever the
license was granted and and the crossing
was made so
um
the adjudication is not really
the the major portion of that process
the major process is what the department
does which is conducting the safety
review to make sure that whatever is
constructed on state lands
or over state waters
doesn't a fear interfere with the
public's use of of that in terms of the
public safety right
so i you know i really think those are
the high points everything else is
really just housekeeping in nature
but you know i'm happy to ask and answer
any questions you might have
yeah
representative mcgee
thank you mr chairman
um i'm just looking at the list uh here
of requests for statutory amendments and
i'm looking at item number four
uh with community power aggregation
and it says to
amend rsa 53e
um
and that review of approval of
responsibilities of the doe would
uh instead of the puc and
i guess i'm
curious i know you said that there are
um
resources from the public utilities
commission who have moved over and are
now performing
similar
functions
as i recall when hb 2 went through we
had several presentations and there was
a discussion a robust discussion about
the bright red line between regulatory
proceedings
which at that time i think rule making
is also was considered part of the
regulatory piece as were adjudicative
proceedings
there would be a bright red line between
um you know the doe which is an agency
under the executive branch and the
regulatory which are
were seen as very distinct so that was
sort of the guarantee we were given can
you explain to us attorney sherlock
how some of these statutory requirements
to switch those regulatory burdens over
to the department of energy
don't
like remove that red line
okay so um
community power aggregation number four
the specific one that you you've looked
at that we're actually continuing to
discuss with the public utilities
commission they're trying to decide
whether that is one that is appropriate
for them to keep
right
the reason that we think it's
appropriate for the department to do is
is it's not really a rate setting
function it's it's it's a review of
basically an aggregator's plan right
with some consumer protection aspect to
it right and those are functions that
are
are really at the department right now
so you know the the department
regulates or oversees competitive
suppliers and competitive aggregators we
didn't see a reason to split off
municipal aggregations from that
there are some very common themes
to the two
and to us they just seemed better
packaged together right
the
commission
has looked at a rulemaking right
so
the staff
had
begun
a rulemaking
um
some time ago to try and get community
aggregation going
um house bill 315
placed that at the
commission
so we took our product
and we petitioned the commission to open
a rulemaking
to accomplish you know the
the legislature's
desires or intent and um
uh
that is now up to the puc to decide so
um
we made a specific proposal and that was
all done publicly right um and there
were responses to that the commission
has decided to
to
do something slightly different from
what the department proposed so all of
that
has been handled
under
the bright red line if you want to call
it that
but
our thought is that that jurisdiction
the whole thing the rule making should
come to the department
right
so it
wouldn't be a violation of that bright
red line it would just be a change in
the jurisdiction back over to to the
department okay follow-up so
follow up thank you
um okay so
i think the other thing that might be
helpful in clarifying for this committee
where we're going it you know it seems
like there's a lot in here to be
translated to the department of energy
it's a new department that's great but i
guess what would be helpful is if you
could clarify
which jurisdictions remain with the
public utilities commission because they
had kind of a breadth of
responsibility for
rule making you know there was rule
making and rate setting and i think a
lot of people thought of them as just
rate setters but an awful lot of what we
tried to throw over the wall for
discussion and decision making
would go to the public utilities
commission and i think it may confuse us
as to what we can send there if we don't
understand in a clear way what is the
public utilities commission left
responsible for
as a separate entity i guess so um
that's a
a very good and a very complicated
question
so
you know do i get points you do
the
both
agencies were given general supervisory
authority uh over the utilities and and
there is some
overlap or in many areas some ambiguity
as to who has responsibility for what
and
we have been working to sort of tease
that apart and and figure out what
should be on which side and we've just
kicked off a
where the public utilities commission
and
the department will be working with the
department of justice to
sort of conduct that exercise by looking
at the existing rules
and figuring out
under the wording of the statute where
those different authorities go
and that process is going to take a
while
we expect to have that done uh sometime
in 2022
and perhaps after that there'll be a
little bit more clarity
and everyone will see because i'm sure
everyone is curious it's not not just
you the utilities wonder well who do we
send this report to and who's really
going to tell us what to do and what if
the department tells us one thing and
the puc tells us another
hopefully over the next year in the
context of that project we'll be able to
separate that out a little bit better
and and provide some clarity
ultimately though
it's going to be up to you where to send
things and and anytime you
you
someone proposes a bill
we will appear
right and the puc will probably appear
and tell you whether we think that
that's an appropriate
whether it's appropriate to go to the pc
or appropriate to come to us and then
the decision will ultimately be the
legislatures
right and and that might be a you know
something that happens on a case-by-case
basis
even after the clarification
right
okay uh representative uh
did you have a question no
thank you mr chairman and thank you mr
shulock for being here and commissioner
kilms
so i have a lot of questions
and i don't expect to ask all of them
today but um
what i really like to hear from you and
uh
it seems to me that we don't really have
enough time to deal with everything you
mentioned you could give us a two and a
half hour presentation which i'd like to
see give to the whole committee and not
just the subcommittee because this is
these are really important issues so as
someone who is very supportive of a
department of energy being created let
me ask you this
what what i think what my concerns and
and unclarities right now are is
who's responsible for what and how does
it change um for example will these will
the department of energy and the puc be
kind of independent of each other or is
there some kind of a dependency that one
will be able to
interfere with the activities of the
other
what areas of the poc that were
regulatory in nature
are somehow going away or being taken
over by the department of energy
and
how does that affect
you know
us moving forward i understand these are
also unresolved questions some of them
for you as well uh but you know
we're talking we're starting to talk
about about nitty gritty details here
but i don't even understand exactly how
what the philosophy is of the
reorganization
what is it for what does it do how is it
independent of each other
for example can the governor's office
have influence on making something
happen in one department and not in the
other or are they independent enough to
to to have the credibility to know
that they are
as much as possible beyond political
influence
um so so i don't think i can answer all
of that instead but um the statutes are
constructed so that the two agencies are
independent agencies
right although the puc is
administratively attached to the
department
so
we can't the department
cannot
tell the public utilities commission how
to decide a case
what we do
is we will appear in a docket and will
present evidence testimony and opinion
just like any other party to that docket
and the public utilities commission will
decide what to do with that maybe they
will agree with it maybe they won't
right
and and they'll fashion their decision
as they see fit
right
so
uh
the
way that the restructuring took took
place the
public utilities commission
is
i mean
dependent is not quite the right word
right
but there were functions that were at
the puc staff members full departments
of
filled with economists and raid analysts
and
utility analysts etc right
who would look at a utilities filing
analyze it prepare testimony and present
the commission no longer has that staff
that staff is at the department and the
way that that staff now interacts with
the commission is through those
adjudicative proceedings
that's how they
communicate in an adjudicative
proceeding is in filings or in the
hearing room
right so
there there is some
some need for us
right to have
the the commission gets a view that is
independent of the utilities
presentation um in in those dockets
but they don't tell us what our view is
and we can't tell them what their order
has to say right we just do our work we
provide them with the opinion and the
evidence and and they do what what they
need to do so there's that relationship
and and you might look at it as some
kind of dependency but
we were really
independent agencies with our own
missions right
can you refresh our memory how many
people are currently working at the puc
chris might be able to give exact
numbers
oh yeah the exact numbers um i i don't
have that for the puc for uh
the department of energy uh the position
count is somewhere uh in the
neighborhood of the low 70s we do have a
number of vacancies as do many state
agencies obviously it's a
it's a difficult workforce time but uh
that's that's what we're built to i
believe the puc is somewhere in the
neighborhood of 20 but they could
provide that information thank you i
appreciate that representative kelly
pitts has a question oh i'm sorry did
you have something to say so
it's sort of related so
the
the the commission has six senior
advisors
now
um
who
can help them figure out
what
the department and all the other parties
mean
right what their what their evidence
means they have a they do have a staff
to help assist them it's just much
smaller
um and
probably will not be capable of doing
all the numbers crunching and and such
that the department does right but they
they do have some staff to advise them
okay thank you representative callie
bits
this is my day for confusion i'm gonna
um i
envisioned
the department of energy as being the
planning
and the sort of pushing where we go as
far as energy goes agency
and now i seem to have in my mind
four balls in the air the puc the
department of energy the sec and the
consumer advocate
and they're hanging there
and to be quite honest i don't know why
one of the questions i have is who funds
the department of energy
and the puc
the consumer advocate and the sec can
you tell me that just
who okay so the um
the office of consumer advocate is
completely funded by utility assessment
right so you
we all pay for that as
through our utility bills right
um the
uh department of energy is funded by the
utility assessment and by some federal
special federal funding you know for
special product projects the laihe
project etc there are a number of those
but those are the only two sources is
that correct
oh rps funding as well right
um
um those are the only two sources of our
operating or three sources of our
operating revenue right the
sec
is funded by applicant fees
and i think now
the general fund there's some small
follow-up please
so
again from what i'm hearing and what i'm
ingesting i would love to see your
presentation by the way
what it seems to me that the consumer
the utility pays the consumer pace the
consumer is now paying for two energy
two
agencies or three
that are doing
almost exactly the same work
and really haven't figured it out yet
and every every
increment of a year that we go a month
two months three months that nobody that
you can't figure out what you're doing
that there's a problem because the
consumer is paying for that that cost is
passed on
and
i i guess
when
i don't understand why it seemed again
is being slowly
dissolved
and
that may not be true
but that's how it appears to me
right now okay
okay so um
my personal view is that the
public utilities commissioner or public
utilities commission
has a smaller role than it used to
and that it is leaner and meaner
or will be meaner shortly after they
staff up right they they still have some
many of the things
that were stripped out of that role
have come over to the department they
were always done
they still need to be done they're just
going to be done by a different agency
and we're doing our very best to ensure
that there will be no duplication of any
efforts in that process and that that is
one of the things that's going to go on
in this rules project that we're
doing this year when we divide the rules
we'll we'll be able
to sh to show everybody that some things
are going to the public utilities
commission and some things are going to
the department and that there's
there isn't as much there won't be as
much overlap
in
the actions of the two agencies as there
might appear to be
in the statutes
right so
we're going to go through that
that exercise this year and try and
divide those things we're very cognizant
of the fact that we don't want to
duplicate
anything
and
we'll just do our best to try and make
i just want to push back a little bit on
the characterization that you know
things aren't getting done you know
docket work continues our division of
regulatory support continues uh you know
to present the state's position uh in
those puc proceedings orders are you
know moving forward that work is is
happening at the puc so regardless of
your opinion on on
you know the the content of that policy
what comes out of those orders that that
work is happening and that is something
where the department has
is is working um you know full on to
help help support that process
uh i would like to respond
uh i
remember we're not here to debate i was
people
presentation regardless of my opinion i
was referred to directly so i would
reserve the right to respond if you have
a question you can respond but my
question do not engage in a debate my
question is did i ever say that that
okay we'll let that one go that's a
rhetorical question
are there any other questions for mr
shulock and mr
elms
i'm just curious there's a lot in this
uh another heading of energy
other than just running the show um
there's policy we've got climate change
worries uh
um there's energy efficiency things like
that are you having any
role in any of those kinds of issues
yeah absolutely so uh the department of
energy has a very varied role in terms
of the various aspects of energy uh
in new hampshire our division of policy
and programs uh administers a number of
federal programs uh our fuel assistance
program our weatherization assistance
program
i don't mean that i mean strategy what's
new hampshire's strategy going to be
well so also within that division uh
they have been charged through hb2 with
the development of the new hampshire
state energy strategy the update to
uh the 2018
state energy strategy so that work is
moving forward within that division
we have a number of other
aspects our enforcement division handles
you know aspects related to safety
we have a consumer group who
looks to consumer protection resolving
disputes between consumers
related to their utility service
our our
uh you know division of administration
works you know contains the division or
the department's uh investigations and
audit staff
so there is a very
wide variety of non-regulatory functions
that fall within the department of
energy
follow-up yes i what but you know the
overall strategy for example the energy
strategy from 2014
was done with a very uh
very very strong
um multifaceted effort with all kinds of
consultants helping and so on the 2018
comes by and there's guys going around
with a
clipboard having listening sessions and
the guy is scribbling on his
on his clipboard and
strategy which
several of us thought was just
abominable remember we're here to ask
questions
uh who's where's the strategy going to
come from
what i mean
just
updating the
2018 to the 2022 strategy is not
nowhere near the the the
the magnitude the importance that was
put into the 2014.
and so
just this sounds like continuing on with
sort of administratively
um representative man please let him
answer the question i'm trying to find
out i'm trying to ask a question let him
answer it please i'm trying to ask if
there's going to be
strategic thinking or are we basically
going to just kind of keep things going
the way they've been going so it is
certainly the department's intention to
uh craft the revision to the state
energy strategy in a strategic way
um
regardless of
various
policy or ideological feelings towards
either the 2014 or 2018 strategy i will
point out that the 2014 strategy
was given to at the time the office of
energy and planning with the 250 000
consulting budget that the 2018
strategy and even now there there is not
a specific you know budget for
uh consultants attached to it and and
you know is left to the expertise of the
department
thank you any uh additional questions
for
the gentleman from the department of
energy we have other people who would
like to testify representative christian
thank you chair thank you for taking my
question
i had a question about the language
on the first page
the new text
lines 14 through 16
about the audit
being conducted of the puc
the part that reads which in the opinion
of the commission or the department of
energy ought to be audited is that
meant to
i guess define the scope of the audit
saying that the department of energy is
able to decide what needs to be audited
or is that kind of editorializing
so
first of all the
commission
has had an auditing staff
for as long as i can remember right
and that auditing staff
um
does certain things on a routine basis
such as whenever a utility
applies
for a full rate increase they file a
full rate increase they base that
increase on a test year
and their expenses
and expenditures during that test year
are fully audited
but by the audit division to make sure
that
the rates are based on a revenue
requirement for the utility that there
is a relationship to reality right and
everything checks out right
before the rates are made right
they also do desk audits
of utilities on small matters
they
audit some of the programs
that that occur
and all of that staff has moved to the
department
the commission no longer has any of that
staff
right
so
if the commission
wants
to
conduct an audit
it has no one on its own staff to turn
to
but if as in the past it thinks that an
audit ought to be done
you know so that it can fill its
statutory requirements whatever they
might be
they want to be able
to have the department do that the
department staff right do that because
that's where they're located right now
that's part of the purpose of this
and then even if
the department doesn't have the staff
the department has the ability to
contract
for outside auditors to do types of
audits that the staff doesn't normally
do say it's a management audit of the
company and the commission really thinks
that one
needs to be done they can ask the
department to do it and the department
can go through the process of hiring
those
those auditing companies to to do that
work so i think that's that that's what
this provision is is primarily about
right
and thank you great
thank you representative mcgee did you
have a question too
i did and it was on another topic but
i'd like to follow on with what
representative creation just said and
just ask
since those resources used to be
assigned to the public utilities
commission was there a benefit to them
having their own in-house people
available to them to help with those
would that work
and those investigations i'm just
curious about the
you know the
organizational
posturing well i think there's
definitely a benefit to having
somebody do that work some sort of
independent objective
agency or
company to to do that work
i don't know that it matters whether
it's specifically the puc
where that's housed or the department
where's where that's housed i think
what's clear and this goes to
representative kelly pitts
questioning we don't need two audit
departments and so we don't need to
support that
so
it's it's housed at the department the
department's auditors can do that work
this provision allows the public
utilities commission
to to task them with that work okay
thank you and can i ask my question
it's on you yes follow up thank you it's
it's on uh on this page again there's a
reference
to provisions that would
be um
that that the department would not be
subject to and it refers to rsa 541
a29 or rsa
541a29a and can you just give us a quick
idea of what that is that we'd be
exempting if we adopted these so 541 8
requires
an agency when it gets any type of
request or application
from some someone in the public
to
respond
um it used to be within 60 days and
until that now it's 30 under the statute
um to tell that person well this is
what's missing from your application or
this is a problem that i have with your
and to ask any questions that needed to
be asked
and then it required action within 60
days
or the opening of an adjudicative
proceeding
for which not all applicant applications
are
suitable for right
and if that didn't happen
then house bill
or i'm sorry it was house bill 1104 with
his where this happened a number of
years ago
but um
29a
says that if if an agency doesn't meet
those deadlines then the approval is
automatically granted as a matter of law
okay so
for some agencies for the things that
they do
that type of automatic approval in those
timelines are either very tight or
impossible or the types of approvals
that they give really
really aren't suitable for that sort of
automatic
uh
operation of law
provision
so when house bill 1104 went through the
legislature a number of agencies were
granted exemptions to those requirements
and the public utility commission
probably got the biggest exemptions of
all right because very few of the things
that come before
the public utilities commission are now
the department are things that are
resolvable within that period of time
right
and
for some of those
those those approvals the results the
consequences of an automatic approval
can be
very
very dramatic right so
you know for instance one of the things
that the
public utilities commission does is it
approves whether a utility
can disconnect or terminate the service
of a customer
who has a medical need for the utility
service so say somebody's on a
respirator at home and they need
electricity they might have a medical
exemption filed with the public
utilities commission the utility might
come in and say well you know they
haven't paid their bill in five years i
really want to turn off the electricity
and
the role that the state has in that is
just to make sure that enough leg work
has been done
to assure that the proper notifications
have been made and and somebody with
that type of condition isn't going to
abruptly
lose their electricity lose their
respirator and die in the middle of the
night right and this stems from an
actual
occurrence right it was a piece of
legislation to solve an actual problem
right
and uh
so you know those those sorts of things
are not resolvable within the short time
period because of the leg work that's
required
and the period
the notification periods etc
and you know
not everything at the commission was
that dramatic but
everything
has enough procedure to it that it takes
a long time to to get to a yes or no
okay
so
when house bill 2 went through
a lot of that work came over to the
department but there were
there was an oversight in
in the exemptions the exemptions didn't
follow so
you know
now we have all those problems at the at
the department right and um if you are
kind enough to actually transfer the
authority for 363 b over to the
department that's the authority for
approving medical disconnects right
we will we will have that problem i mean
currently the commission
because the exemption didn't move and
the statute didn't move the commission's
not subject to five
uh to 29a but if it comes over and we
don't get this type of exemption
we'll be subject to that
that time period thank you i've heard of
this before i just wasn't sure in
looking to the reference i didn't i
didn't know what we were talking about
but that's sufficient for me
thank you very much thank you all right
um gentlemen i want to thank you for
your testimony here today i'd like to
ask if
clifton below is still in the room ah
there you are i'd like to call
uh as our next testifier the honorable
clifton below
who's here to testify on behalf of
himself
but it's always a pleasure to uh to have
mr bilo here with us so cliff take it
away uh thank you good afternoon members
of the committee um i just want to thank
representative harrington for bringing
this bill forward and say i'm generally
supportive of the idea of trying to
straighten these things out and i would
hope that folks could try to work on a
bipartisan basis there are some policy
questions i'm not
sure one way or the other on a few of
them myself but you'll have to make
those decisions i'm mainly here to
address uh one particular issue um
that's not mentioned from the doe on the
very last page of the bill
under um section 20 there's three
repeals
at line six there's a repeal of rsa 374
f
three roman four
and that's one of the restructuring
policy principles that was enacted by
this body 26 years ago and just in that
context
back 26 years ago in 1996 there was a
major federal policy effort going on
with the federal energy regulatory
commission
to open up non-discriminatory access to
the transmission grid to promote uh
competition in the interstate wholesale
markets and
that order actually came out just a
month after the new hampshire house
passed similar language into law and and
what this would repeal um
is
one of the restructuring policy
principles which were enacted rather
than trying to be real prescriptive
about how we uh restructured the
industry we said set forth a set of
principles to guide the puc too loud or
stupid can't keep up with you way too
fast okay okay sorry i'll slow down
um so
the fourth restructuring policy
principle um
and it is real simple it says open
access to transmission and distribution
facilities that's the title and it says
non-discriminatory open access to the
electric system for wholesale and
retrail retail transactions should be
promoted
that's the important principle and and
there's three more sentences that follow
which are kind of out of date and i'm
guessing uh that somebody looking at the
rest of that said oh this stuff doesn't
really make sense anymore so repeal the
whole thing
so my ask would be don't repeal the
whole thing keep at least that first
sentence which is sort of foundational
to the idea of competition and customer
choice and when
in statutory interpretation when
something's repealed it's taken to have
some meaning and impact and i i
federal law controls open
non-discriminatory access to
transmission but i think we want to have
that same principle or else you're
you're suggesting that maybe we should
repeal the whole statute and get rid of
customer choice and competition that
that's the main thing i did want to
comment on a couple things that have
just come up today real quickly excuse
me could you before we leave this
subject could you tell us
a little bit more about
what that
access
would provide
well what what it really means an
example yeah um it means that if uh
um a business like this or institutions
the state of new hampshire or any
business uh wanted to choose their
supplier rather than the utility default
service they wanted to go with a
different competitive electric supplier
it means that they could choose the
competitive electric supplier and the
power could access
onto the grid
and um to the customer
and
the if the utility for instance owned
generation they wouldn't have an
advantage in the terms
or access to the grid for
uh customers getting their electricity
supply
the the it used to be
uh before restructuring both at the
federal and state level that if utility
owned
just transmission or distribution they
could say you cannot sell power over our
our system um
and and they would block they would
discriminate they would make deals with
some uh suppliers and some off takers
but not others and so that's why
congress
uh directed ferc
uh to um move in this direction and this
has really been broadly um embraced by
the industry as a better approach than a
heavy regulatory approach to these
questions
just open non-discriminatory
access for these retail and wholesale
transactions
is it still an issue in the absence of
utility owned generation
um
this is what is essentially the
condition today but the question would
be if you're repealing that does that
mean that doesn't that's not important
anymore um
it's just i i i wouldn't see why you'd
want to repeal that principle because
it's sort of foundational uh to how
we work in new hampshire and most of new
england it's not not true in vermont
you can't choose a different supplier of
your power than the vertically or or the
one monopoly utility there's no customer
choice um so that that that's sort of
where it's connected to
okay the other uh two things i just want
to mention i i don't really take a
position at this point because i it's
the first i've heard of it of who's
going to review electric aggregations
plans for community power aggregation um
i would say
that it's not really a regulatory
function the review is for conformity
with applicable statutes and rules
um
and it does seem like a
just at first plus it seems like the
pucs appropriate for that because their
their main job is to see
how does the law apply how do the rules
apply
um are people meeting them that you know
they're just sort of a neutral uh body
for that but but i'm happy i'm happy to
work with the department and the
subcommittee if that's of any help to to
think this through because i don't have
a firm position on that um
the other issue i just wanted to mention
is poll attachments there's just one
little part of this bill that touches on
that
but looking that at that more
generally
i think there's some
there's some issues that bear further
thought in the subcommittee and i'll
back in
before 2007 the state did not have the
authority to regulate poll attachments
congress gave that authority to the
federal communications commission to
promote and actually use the term open
non-discriminatory access to polls for
competition cable companies and
competitive telecom providers which have
obviously produced enormous benefits for
econom our economy to have that
competition
um it was a big issue i i was on the on
the commission at that time cliff excuse
me are you referring to
uh section 15 of the bill as introduced
yes okay thank you thank you um
and and
we had a backlog of complaints from
telecom providers wanting to attach to
polls
frustrated with the incumbent utilities
and their only recourse was to file a
complaint with the fcc which would just
sit around for years
and and so um
they asked if we couldn't take on that
job and there's a specific federal
statute that's referred to here
that said okay states are preempted from
this
but if you meet all these criteria
and you certify that you
do this then the states can do this for
in lieu of the fcc is sort of a
delegation of federal authority and and
the one little sentence in here is just
part of what was added as part of house
bill two
and it you know the bill says you know
back to the commission the department
said well maybe that really should say
doe
when i'm looking at the whole statute
which i won't go into
i think there's some things to sort out
because there was an effort to sort of
split the roles and say well the
commission
in the underlying statute as it now
reads the commission can settle disputes
and regulate and enforce rates and
charges but it's the department of
energy that in carrying it out its role
in this is the one that considers the
interests of subscribers and users of
the services offered via such
attachments as well as the interest of
consumers of any poll owner providing
such attachments that's a balancing test
a regulatory balancing test
and
the underlying statute actually
pretty much indicates that regulatory
that responsibility to do a balancing
test between different interests
needs to go with the authority to
regulate the rates and the way
the statute is at the moment the
commission does not have the that
responsibility to do that balancing test
although that's kind of what they
traditionally do that's been moved over
to doe and
i'm not going to say we're not in
conformity with the federal statute but
but
there might be an issue here that could
be cleaned up along the way and that
that's that's all i'm saying and and i
just i i'm familiar with this because at
the time i was sort of the commission's
point person and helped write this rsa
374 34a
and worked with our own attorneys the
department of justice and the fcc to
make sure that we're compliant
with what allowed us to take over this
authority and um
and and then i also worked on the
initial poll attachment rules quite a
bit um so i
it's just something that you know
representative harrington has asked me
you know somebody who's a former
commissioner has worked with the stuff
to you know if i might be another set of
eyes on this and think about this so
that that's just one little area that i
thought i could contribute a little
insight on
so thank you thank you questions for
representative mcgee thank you mr
chairman and thank you mr bilo nice to
see you again
um okay so what you were just explaining
i was taking some notes on the poll
attachment authority coming from the fcc
so
in the way that you described it it
sounds like what you were saying is when
you split that authority
you are further diluting what the fcc
intended when they said that they would
provide that authority down to the
public utilities commission level
less clear whether or not
another agency would be able to take
that authority is that correct that's
what i thought i heard you say right so
i'll just be specific one thing this
47 usc
um
i'm not seeing the whole number but it's
referenced in the underlying statute you
don't see it but it's in
34a
it's 47 usc section 224c
and one part of what that says is that
each state
which regulates terms and conditions for
poll attachments shall certify to the
commission meaning the federal
communication commission that
a
it regulates such terms
rates terms and conditions and to be in
so regulating such rates terms and
conditions the state has the authority
to consider and does consider
the interests of the subscribers of the
services offered by such attachments
meaning basically cable and telecom
people who are getting service from
cable and telecom
as well as the interest of the consumers
of the utility services meaning
the customers of the electric utility
and the incumbent
um you know wires uh telecom company
and and and so it's a it's a little
unusual balancing test but it's two
different consumer groups that have an
interest in terms and conditions and
rates for poll attachments
and what the split up of the two uh did
is it says
yeah okay the commission still has some
ra regulates rates terms and conditions
but it's the doe
under it's because the rules were moved
to doe that has this balancing
responsibility
and i think the federal statute says in
so regulating the state
will consider these factors and and the
statute as it reads now doesn't direct
the commission to do this balancing test
it's in the department of energy when in
fact
it's
the regulation of some of this is still
with the the
commission
and that's a little bit confusing about
what's in the bill because it it refers
to
the puc retaining authority to regulate
a bunch of things
but includes poll attachments
and often the reference to conduits
ducts pipes all that is also in the
federal regulations it's sort of all
under the poll attachment rubric
um
so i'm just saying that there's things
that could be cleaned up better to to
make our this this overall statutory
scheme more uh resilient over the long
term and you know make sure it's just
a meeting you know in this case a
federal requirement it's it's a minor
provider fix i think thank you i hope
you can provide guidance to the uh
subcommittee that sure
sure thank you
other questions for
the honorable mr bilo
we have one other person who would like
to testify this afternoon and that's
eric wind of the puc
so thank you mr bilo we appreciate you
being here
and mr wind
we'll look forward to hearing what you
have to say thank you for being here
certainly thank you chairman and it's an
honor to be here addressing all this
afternoon
um i don't have a
my name is eric wind first of all and
i'm a senior advisor at the public
utilities commission and an attorney
i don't have extensive testimony i can
just report that we're pleased to have
been able to work with our colleagues at
the department of energy
to do this house to prepare this house
cleaning legislation
and i'm mostly just here to answer any
questions that may arise so
hearing
some of the previous questions and
testimony i will address a few
things first of all
the audit function is something that the
commission considers a high priority the
ability to direct
the department of energy's audit
department to perform audits on certain
issues if it deems it necessary and that
really is a matter of administrative
efficiency if the commission at this
point were to simply request
the um department of energy to perform a
certain audit it's not to say that they
wouldn't turn that they would be likely
to turn it down
but
it's just
prevents any scenario where
duplicative staff has to be employed or
an rfp to seek outside
services has to be gone through in order
to have such an audit performed if the
commission finds it necessary
there was also a question about staffing
so i did a head count in my
head right now and the commission has a
total of 14 staff right now including
the three full-time commissioners and
the one special commissioner so 10
support staff supporting the members of
the commission
with that said i'm happy to answer any
further questions on any other
matters
i guess before that i'm sorry to
backtrack a little um
the two ones that i would categorize as
most in need of further study from the
commission's perspective right now
do relate to poll attachments and um
whether or not to move community power
aggregation review
um so i can answer questions if there
are any on those specific subjects but
those are the two areas that kind of
raise the most eyebrows and that we have
ongoing questions about
well i have a question uh thank you very
much for for that
introduction did i understand you
correctly to say that you did work
directly with
mr shulock uh and others to
put together
the suggested amendments that we're
looking at here
the
either members of the commission or
staff of the commission have worked
directly with the department of energy i
did not become involved in this until
yesterday but i did sit down with mr
shulock yesterday and had some
preliminary discussions and went over
these matters and so i'm i can report
that
what's in the version as filed the
commission either supports or does not
take a position on
okay excellent great thank you
uh additional questions for mr wind
come on folks this is your chance to
really understand this stuff
okay
uh representative platt i'm reticent
with questions because they think
they're premature a study committee has
to do its work then questions are
appropriate
well the subcommittee i think is going
to
it's not a study committee it's a
subcommittee
and i think they're going to be putting
together an amendment
representative harrington might want to
speak to that point what do you think
the subcommittee will do representative
harry well the goal is to um take the
this input that we've had today and any
others that people can provide us during
the subcommittee uh meetings and to come
up with an amendment that would uh try
to clean up as many loose ends as
possible for this again this is one
where we don't want uh perfect to
prevent good because some things we're
not going to be able to know how to make
them best until people are actually out
there doing them for another six months
or a year so i'm sure this will not be
the very last uh bill that we address on
this thing but hopefully we can correct
as much as possible so we're looking for
uh import in i know because of this is
running very late now but certainly uh
well i would look for input from the
utilities on the subcommittee uh as well
and any anybody else that could help out
but that would be the goal up with an
amendment
great thank you representative samsit
yes i do mr chairman thank you and uh
thank you mr winn
uh i just wanted to highlight again or
just ask you because you just
volunteered something
what do you think are the
maybe the top three
basic
most important concerns from your
perspective from the puc you already
mentioned
the poll issue
and also the community power is there
anything else that's considered to be
i guess i'll clarify that with the
poll issue and the community power
there are factors that we want to make
sure are considered
in making the right decision and having
the general court here make the right
decision
as far as where that authority lies and
i think that that gets into policy and
gets into substance and the
commission is not
going to volunteer policy
um opinions that's the job of the
department of energy
um but
there are just other factors that i
think would need to be clarified or
flushed out through a more deliberative
process
um as far as the
what of the requests before you today in
the um legislation is introduced the
priorities of the commission
section 11 of the bill require regarding
affiliate agreements i think that that
needs
some resolution because it would appear
to create more work for the commission
presently
the
commission receives affiliate agreements
between utilities or utility entities
and the ability and has the ability to
review them but is not required to take
the affirmative step of approving it
and so that seems to be in the
legislation that
an affirmative approval is now required
and we just want to make sure that
i believe there was one other um
that
is a commission request and would be a
priority of section 17
and that is
a slight tweak to that in the first
sentence would add and the commission
following the department
to authorize the commission to
participate in matters before the
federal energy regulatory commission and
other bodies
there are just some scenarios that have
we can think of
where the commission may also need to be
authorized to appear before ferc
thank you chair thanks for taking my
question um i had a question on the last
page i guess section 20 going back to
the repeals
so we hit two and three
but i was looking at number one
and if i'm looking at the right rsa
which i hope i am it seems to be
repealing the requirement that no member
of the commission um shall also be
either on the legal team of a public
utility or
rendering any professional service um
can you just speak to
have you seen that um prohibition
causing any trouble or why is that being
repealed
so i think i can give a little bit of
color on that without deferring to the
department of energy my understanding is
that this is one that they have
requested but my understanding is also
that it is duplicative of a statutory
provision in chapter 363 so i don't
believe that anything is actually being
repealed here but it's a duplicative
provision
thank you for that clarification
okay any further
questions
seeing none we thank you mr winn for
being here uh staying so late in the
into the evening
uh hope your day is done at this point
uh and we thank you uh
members of the department of energy for
being here
and the honorable clifton below
and our good friend
mr roberge thanks all of you for being
here today so our next order of business
i'm going to close the public hearing
on this bill but our next order of
business will be to form a subcommittee
to
get to work on producing this amendment
so i know representative harrington is
going to lead the subcommittee
representative plett has volunteered to
be on the subcommittee
representative samsich wants to be on
the committee representative mcgee wants
to be on the committee
and uh
we need one more member of the majority
representative bernardi would you be on
i love volunteers volunteers are great
and
so we have a subcommittee set
representative harrington will organize
the first meeting
i suspect there will be more than one to
this is not an early bill so we don't
have to execute
probably as late as early march we could
execute
so you've got some time to put it
together but um you need to get started
i think because it looks like it's
complex process i'll talk with you later
about how to set up the meetings and
which rooms are available and so forth
so right because i know that's a little
more complicated than it has been in the
past
and with that i will thank you all for
being here today
another uh full day of hard work i
appreciate everybody's questions i
appreciate every appreciate everybody's
attendance
and we'll look forward to seeing you
again
a week from today on february 1st where
we will hear
five more bills
a poundage limit on the amount of
allowable pfas
air emissions which ought to be an
there will be a subcommittee meeting on
the 31st uh yeah cheer up by yeah you'll
get a notice how this week from um
what's your name carrie morris carrie it
it'll be monday the 31st at 10 p.m in
it's the exact session the seventh or
eighth
the exact sessions is is that gonna be
the seventh or the eighth is it a monday
or tuesday i thought i heard seventh but
that's a monday
executive session will be monday monday
you